COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
IN RESPONSE TO THE CALL THE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLICLY JUST
LEADERS AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING A FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES TO ENSURE THAT
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WHATSOEVER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
MEMBERS ARE MEMBER OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE ATTENDING
ROUGHLY TODAY IS CENTERED
LIMóN. SINCE HE ANNOUNCED OKAY
I DO NOT SEE HER ARE AND YET
BUT WHEN SHE DOES COME ON WE
WILL INTRODUCE HER- SENATORS-
PLEASE AS A REMINDER PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES FOR THOSE THIS
ME REMOTELY. PLEASE MAKE YOUR
PHONES COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN LIMITING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I DO ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH WE
RECOGNIZE THAT USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT THE ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING IN OUR I. T.
PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE
WHEN YOUR DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT
YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN
THAT YOUR NAME. AND THEN YOU
ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON A COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. AGAIN. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. THREE FIVE ONE. FOUR
ONE NINE EIGHT AGAIN. THREE
FIVE ONE FOUR ONE NINE EIGHT.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES THEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE DO MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND YOU ARE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
HEAR YOU. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. AS CHAIR I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. TODAY WE
HAVE TEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA THE FOLLOWING FIGHT ON
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS FILE ITEMS
ARE UNDER CONSENT CALENDAR
THOSE ARE ITEMS NUMBER FOUR S.
BEFORE SIXTY BY CENTER PAN
MYSELF I AM NUMBER FIVE SB
FORTY SEVEN BY CENTER RUBIO AND
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE FROM THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH. BILLS WILL BE HEARD
TODAY IN FILE ORDER THE ORDER
MAY BE MODIFIED BECAUSE OF THE
VEIL ABILITY BILL AUTHORS TO BE
PRESENT AND THE NEED TO
COMPLETE THE HEARING AGENDA IN
A TIMELY MANNER. LET'S SEE HOW
WE DOING ON ONE TWO THREE FOUR.
FIVE SIX WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
OKAY OKAY S. C. THE ABSENCE OF
A PRESENTLY WILL CONTINUE AS A
SUB COMMITTEE AND THEN WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT WE WILL
THEN TAKE THE ROLE FOR BILL
TESTIMONY DUE DATE THE
CONSTRAINTS OF THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
MYSELF MAY INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON BILL TESTIMONY EACH
TIME WILL BE PERMITTED AN EQUAL
EACH SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED
EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE
DETERMINED BY THE CHAIR. FOR
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION OUT PERMIT TWO
WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS ARE A MAXIMUM OF FOUR
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. OF COURSE YOU ARE
ALWAYS ABLE TO SUBMIT LETTERS
OR COMMENTS TO OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE ON ANY BILLS THAT WE
ARE HEARING. I DO HOPE TO HEAR
FROM EVERYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY HOWEVER BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A DEFINITE TIME FOR THE
END OF THE HEARING. I MAY LIMIT
THE TOTAL TIME FOR ALL COMMENTS
ON A BILL TO ENSURE THE
COMMITTEES ABLE TO COMPLETE OUR
HEARING AGENDA TODAY. AGAIN
EVERYONE ALSO HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT TESTIMONY
ANY BEING ANY BILL BEING HEARD
TODAY ON THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. SO WITH CATS- STEVE
STILL HAVE REMOTE AND TWO IS
NOT. YOU. ONE THREE FOUR SIX.
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM. I THANK
FOR SOCIAL QUESTION. THREE FIVE
SO IF. SEVEN OF. SIX OKAY ALL
RIGHT OKAY WE ARE GOOD SO- THE
WE BEGIN- LET'S GO- BUT THE
STAFF WAS A CONSULTANT CALL THE
ROLL. PAN HERE HAND HERE EGGMAN
I'M SORRY MELENDEZ EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HE GONZALEZ HERE AND SO
HERE GROW HER. LEYVA HERE LEAVE
A- LIMON ROTH. ROTH HERE RUBIO
HERE RUBIO HERE WIENER WIENER
HERE. THANK YOU A HAS
ESTABLISHED YOU. RIGHT SO WE
WILL NOW BEGIN WITH THEIR FIRST
BILL WHICH IS I NUMBER ONE SB
SIXTY FIVE BY SKI WELCOME
CENTER SKINNER- YOU YOU MAY
BEGIN THANK YOU SO MUCH- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE VERY
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB SIXTY
FIVE WHICH IS CALIFORNIA'S MOM
TO THIS BILL- YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
SOME OF THE PRESS. ABOUT THE
CONGRESSIONAL BILL CALLED THE
MOMENT OF THIS ACT WHICH A
NUMBER OF CONGRESS MEMBERS HAVE
INTRODUCED. TO ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT. THE INFANT AND MATERNAL
MORTALITY RATE IS HIGHER IN.
THE US THEN ALL G. EIGHT
COUNTRIES SEVEN YOU KNOW U. S.
IS ONE OF THE G. COUNTRIES THAT
MEANS WE ARE THE HIGHEST. IN
TERMS OF- ECONOMIC OUTPUT OF
ANY COUNTRIES. AND SUPPOSEDLY
EDUCATIONAL LEVELS AND OTHER
THINGS. AND ALL OF THOSE
COUNTRIES HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES
IN BIRTHING. AND IN INFANCY.
THEN THE UNITED STATES. MOST OF
THESE DEATHS ARE PREVENTABLE
NOW ADDITIONALLY. THESE NUMBERS
ARE SKEWED EVEN FURTHER WHEN
YOU LOOK ACT PREGNANT. MOTHERS
OF COLOR AN INFERENCE OF COLOR
ESPECIALLY BLACK BLACK MOTHERS
ARE THREE TO FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO DIE DUE TO PREGNANCY
OR CHILDBIRTH CAUSES. THAN
WHITE MOTHERS DAY ON TO BLACK
BABIES ARE TWO TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO DIE IN INFANCY THESE
STATS ARE INDEPENDENT OF A
BLACK MOTHERS INCOME OR
EDUCATION LEVELS AND WE CAN
TURN TO SERENA WILLIAMS AND
BEYONCE SAY AS TWO GREAT
EXAMPLES OF THIS. AND WHAT THE
RESEARCH HAS INDICATED IS THAT
THERE ARE VARIOUS RACIAL.
SYSTEMATIC RACIAL FACTORS IN
SOCIAL ECONOMIC FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR. SB SIXTY FIVE
SPECIFICALLY BUILDS ON
LEGISLATION THAT SENATOR
MITCHELL AND- INTRODUCING WE
PASSED AND SIGNED INTO LAW THAT
ESTABLISHED AN IMPLICIT BIAS
PROGRAM FOR PERINATAL CARE
PROVIDERS IN SB SIXTY FIVE
TAKES IT A LITTLE FURTHER. BY
ESTABLISHING AND CODIFYING THE
PREGNANCY MORTALITY REVIEW
BOARD. INCLUDING REQUIREMENTS
ON THE EXPERTISE OF THE BOARD%
MEMBERS. SB SIXTY FIVE ALSO
ALLOWS. A BIRTHING PEOPLE TO
STAY ON MEDICAID UP TO A YEAR
AFTER BIRTH AND IT EXTENDS CAL
WORKS BENEFITS TO LOW INCOME
PREGNANT WITH HIGHER MONTHLY
STEINMAN STIPENDS AND IT MAKES
WHAT IS WE UNDERSTAND FROM THE
TERM CAL WORKS WE KNOW THAT
PART OF THE REQUIREMENT IS A
WORK REQUIREMENT. BUT IT MAKES
THE WORKING OPTIONAL WHILE
PREGNANT FINALLY IT- IT HAS
MEDIC CAL EXPANDING WHAT
SERVICES IT WOULD COVER
INCLUDING DO LIKE HERE. BECAUSE
WE- HAVE IN THE RESEARCH THAT
THE PROVISION OF DOULAS TO A
PREGNANT PERSON IS GREATLY
ENHANCES THEIR- BOTH THE
INFANT. BLESSED INFANT
MORTALITY IN BETTER OUTCOMES
FOR THE PREGNANT PERSON. AND IT
PROVIDES FUNDING TO BUILD THE
WORK FORCE AMONG MIDWIFE'S- IN
WITHOUT I WANT TO HAVE MY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- I HAVE.
BHUSRI KEY COULD YOU MOVE FROM
THE MARCH OF DIMES AND
NORTHEAST FLINT FROM BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS SECTION
PROJECT. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER BEFORE MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND I AM
YES I AM HAPPILY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDS AND I'M SORRY
I DID NOT OPEN WITH THAT. THANK
YOU YES SO THE ACTUALLY THE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN UP IN
THE SUBSEQUENT COMMITTEE IF IT
PASSES OUT HERE SO THAT'S WHAT
YOU DON'T HAVE A MOCK UP HERE.
BUT DEAL I UNDERSTAND THEY'LL
BE ACCEPTED IN- HUMAN SERVICES
THANK YOU CENTER KINNER FOR
CLARIFYING THAT RIGHT LET'S
MOVE TO THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- WE HAVE A MEASURE AQUI
COULDN'T MOVE THE- OF MATERNAL
INFANT HEALTH AT MARCH OF
DIMES. AND- NORTHEAST FLINT'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OF BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT AND POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
THE BLACK WHEN FULL- WELLNESS-
MODERATOR KEY PLEASE BRING THEM
ON THE LINE AND I. BELIEVE WE
START OFF WITH MARK. MAJORITY
COULD MOVE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES SO YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO GO YOU FOR MINUTES OF YOUR
RUN OVER YOU TAKE THE PERSON'S
I'LL GIVE YOU MET MORE SO BEGIN.
THANK YOU FOR MY IN ORDER ISN'T
FOR HAVE ME TODAY. MY NAME IS
MUCH. ON THE ANTENNA TURNOUT TO
RUN KIRK- MARCH OF DIMES. I'LL
MARCH DIMES IS ONE OF OLDEST
LARGEST NATIONAL. FIVE FOR THE
HELP THE MOM TO BABIES. AND OUR
WORK IS INCOME FOR TODAY. WE IN
THE MIDDLE A MATURE INFANT
HEALTH PRICE. SENATOR KENNEDY.
THE DATA WE KNOW THE- BIRTH IS
RAISING WINTER MUCH. RATE RIGHT.
AND LEAVE WE- ARE THERE TO.
INCREDIBLE DISPARITIES. IN
THEIR POCKET PETER BERGEN TOXIC.
BECAUSE THE- BABY. PREACHER AND
THE ENTIRE. SKINNER DISCUSS ANY
COMMON EDUCATION INSURANCE ARE
NOT PROTECTIVE FACTORS. I HAVE
THREE SISTERS WE HAVE COLLEGE
DEGREES FROM UC BERKELEY
SACRAMENTO. HOW CAN WE ALL HAD
BABY THIRTY SEVEN WEEKS EARLIER
AND OUR EDUCATION HEALTHY DIET
PRIVATE INSURANCE. COVERAGE
COULD NOT PROTECT THAT FROM
DISRESPECTFUL. AND POOR
OUTCOMES. SHOULD DROP THAT. WE
NEED COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSES.
BY POLICY MAKERS SIMPLY ACCESS
THE QUALITY RESPECTFULLY
SPONSORED IMPAIR NAIL CARE. TO
MEDICAID SOCIAL DRIVERS THAT
HELP BY. POVERTY AND FOR POST
CARE TO DRIVE MATERNAL HEALTH
AND CHRONIC IN THAT IMPACT
HEALTH WE DON'T NEED BETTER
BECAUSE- SIMPLE IT BACK IN THE-
AND POLICIES THAT THE TRAIN. AS
A MEMBER OF THE SOUTHERN.
PRACTICE WHEN THEY MURTALA
REVIEW HI THEM CORNER OF HAVING
IDEA. EXPLORE COMMITTEE THAT
ADDRESSES THE TERM OF HEALTH
AND MAKES RECOMMENDED FOR
PRACTICE. THE MARCHES TO PLEASE
THE COR AT THREE SIX THE FIVE
MAKES BIRTHDAY. TO DRIVE
ATTORNEY HEALTH THIS. PARTNERS
BUT NOT AS A QUICK. BONTA
MATERNAL HEALTH AND I. WHO
MAKES DRIVE TO PRETERM BIRTH
PREVENTABLE DEATHS AND DRIVE
THE BASE TO HELP THE FRIDAY TO
HI CALIFORNIA'S MODERATE AND
PARTS OF SOUTH. FORTUNE TO
READY TO WORK WITH YOU TO
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW THE BRING UP-
NOBODY'S FRIEND YOU HAVE A- AND
SO NOW. IT CHERNYKH COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS THEY'RE BASICALLY
NINE THAT CORRECT OF LUCK WITH
A LOT OF ACTION. THE NEW YORK
BONTA WITH YOUR TODAY I WANT TO
SEE WITH YOU I'M A PART OF IT
AT THE END OF MY CHILD MY
FRIEND ACTING WHEN I'M GOING TO
DO OFFICE PART. OKAY BECAUSE
THE WORK I HAVEN'T GOT AROUND
TO IT. BECAUSE I TERRIFIED. THE
THOUGHT OF HAVING TO.
COMPLETELY CHILD THAT I CARRY
BUT NEVER WHICH TO DO I'M AYE
MA AYE PARTNER HAS TO BILLS
BECAUSE THAT. HE DID IT MAKE IT
ME UP AT NIGHT. THANK YOU AT
THE RIGHT LETTERS TO LET MY
BABY NOW IF I'M NOT AROUND HE
IS NOT SO MUCH. WITH MY COUNTY.
AND EVEN WITH MY POLITICALLY.
OVER A DECADE OF EXPERIENCE.
HOW COVERAGE OF HAVING PEOPLE
BE CORRECTED ABOUT WE- STILL
HAVE PROTECT THE- TREATED AT
THE HOSPITAL. THE BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS I OF THE
NETWORK TO GET CREATIVE HERE.
THE ONLY BE IN THAT I DIDN'T
MAKE. IF THAT THE WAY HELPFUL
BUCKLEY THAT. IS WHAT THE ON
SIX HAVE A HI BY NOT THAT MY
DOCTOR BOTHER. NOBODY. SB SIX
FIVE OUT OF FOUR PEOPLE AT.
EVERY ISSUE WITH THE KELLY CARE
CALICO BUT IT IS HOME. TO THE
STATE HELLO ADVOCATE THAT LIMIT
ARE YOU A LOT. WE ARE BACK THE
NUMBER. THE SIXTY FIVE SUPPORT
FIRST- GO TO THE PUBLIC
GALLERY- SAYING NO ONE
APPROACHING MIKE FROM THE
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM AT THE TWENTY FORTY WHICH
REMEMBER IN. OKAY SAYING NO
AND- IN THAT ROOM LET'S MOVE TO
TELEPHONIC LINE- YES A ROOM TO
A FORTY SOMETHING SO-
TELEPHONICALLY TO MODERATOR-
PLEASE ALLOW PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. SIXTY
FIVE TO COME ON THE LINE- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT. SB SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND LINE SEVENTY TWO YEAR MIKE
IS UP. PLEASE. LINE SEVENTY TWO
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE. NINE THIRTY
SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. LINE
THIRTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
FIVE THIRTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MARC
SYCAMORE WITH PUBLIC LAWCENTER
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY FIVE. OKAY THANK YOU
NECKLINE. LINE SEVENTY HERE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON LORI
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER AND
POP PROUD COSTA IN STRONG.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WHY EIGHTY
NINE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- VIDEOTON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE TOUCH OLD
FRENCH MEMORIAL FOUNDATION
CALLING INSTRUCT THE PORT SB
SIXTY FIVE I WANT VOEPEL AND
THAT MIGHT IT WILL JUST TAKING
DARING EXIST DOES PLEASE THANK
YOU SO MUCH- NEXT LINE. LINE
SIX SIX YOUR MIKE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
COLD WATER ON BEHALF OF THE TWO
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT. BLIND TWENTY EIGHT- MY
COULD UP. GOOD AFTERNOON TO
MEMBER NO ATWATER MALL WITH
CALIFORNIA WILL ASSISTANCE
FOUND. IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU LINE. WHY NO ONE ONE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. BANNON SENATORS
MATTER COUNTS FOR COULD WATCH
AND OF SIX FIVE THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LINE NINETY FIVE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. DIANA DOUGLAS
HEALTH CAL IN STRONG OF S.
SIXTY THANK YOU NEXT. LINE
EIGHTY YOUR AT THE- GOOD
AFTERNOON YOU CAN WITH THE
CALIBER BLACK HILL NETWORK
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LINE ONE HI TWENTY YOU'RE
MY AT THE- GOOD AFTERNOON
RONALD HERE BEHALF OF THE PAN
AND CALVIN IS SO THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LINE AT ONE HUNDRED TWO
YOUR MIKE OPEN. AFTERNOON THAT
IS DEBBIE CAN DAHLE SUMMER DOWN
BEACH HELP AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY BY. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE TWENTY
SIX YOUR MIKE OPEN. SH GOOD
AFTERNOON DONNA THANK HER THE
ANGELES COUNTY BY IS TO. IS THE
OF THAT SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
NEXT. LINE ONE HI THIRTY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MOLLY ROPES AND
PRINTER OF SELLING OF HOW IN
STRONG. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
WHITE FOUR YEAR MIKE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBER AND
PACKED THE AC OF CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU LINE. LINE SIXTY
THREE YEAR MIKE IS UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON ONE THE OTHER ON
BEHALF OF THE ALL WITH. FOR BE
IMPAIRMENT CONSTRUCTED BUT
COULD BE. THANK YOU LINE. BLIND
ONE FOUR YOUR MIKE OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS HUNDRED TRAINING OR
ABORTION ACCOUNT FOR HEALTH
CARE IN STRONG OF LEAST SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. BLIGHTED THIRD SEVEN YOUR
MIKE OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
TERRY MEMBERS K<c.cyan> LATER ON</c>
BEHALF THE TOLD SPECIAL CARE CO
CALLING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF A
FEW FIVE THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
WINDS SAID YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
CANELO. AND HERE CAME EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
URBAN INSTITUTE WE STAND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY YOU'RE MY COULD THAT MEAN
FOR ME YES PLEASE BEGIN. HI MY
NAME IS LIZ DONNELLY AND I AM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSE
MIDWIFE ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT COOK PROUD CO SPONSORS
OF THE BILL AND TRYING TO THINK
THANK YOU. NEXT LINE. LINE
SIXTY FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS MAKING
AMERICA THEIR WORK AT THE UCSF
SCHOOL OF NURSING IN A WOMEN'S
POLICY INSTITUTE HELLO IN
STRONG SUPPORT HE COULD GET
BACK. THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
LEYVA ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. POLICE
SEVENTY MODEL WITH THAT IT VERY
FAITH MINNITI CHANGE- TROPICAL
OF THAT THE THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. BLIND AND NINETY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CANDACE
CROSS ON BEHALF OF THE PRACTICE
PROJECT HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
AT THE SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
EXLINE. BLIND OF ONE HUNDRED
FORTY YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS LIZ GLADMAN I'M WITH
A IN- AND LOOKS OUT THEY CARED
IN MANHATTAN AND REDONDO BEACH
AND I MET IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THAT THE SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE
NINETY TO HEAR MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS CHANTE
DAY BEFALLS PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF BLACK WELLNESS AND
PROSPERITY CENTER IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANKS LINE. LINE
NINETY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KATRINA
CANTRELL WOMEN'S HEALTH
SPECIALISTS THE FEMINIST
WOMEN'S HEALTH CENTER IN CHICO
READING AND GRASS VALLEY WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LINE SIXTY NINE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS HAPPY I'M FROM
STRENGTH BASED COMMUNITY CHANGE
IN LOVINGTON CALIFORNIA AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT SB SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU EXLINE. LINE
NINETY ONE NEAR MY COULD OPEN.
HYEN TRISH VINCENT BEHALF OF
THE LEGAL AID SOCIETY SAN
MATTEO COUNTY WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB SIXTY FIVE. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SAVANNAH WASHINGTON I'M A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE OUT OF
SUNNYVALE CALIFORNIA I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY
FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
WHITE ONE HUNDRED YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JANETTE
ROBINSON FLINT I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS SH AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
TO HEAR MY COULD OPEN. HELLO
ANDREW SANCHEZ WITH STRENGTH
BASED COMMUNITY CHANGE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION IN
WILMINGTON CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. SIXTY FIVE
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE
SEVENTY SIX OR MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO YES PLEASE INTERNET
CONNECTION HERE WITH STRING
BASS COMMUNITY CHANGE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU EXLINE. ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR MICROSCOPE. HI MY NAME IS
IRENE MORENO. GREEN BAY
COMMUNITY GENERAL MAKING
CALIFORNIA THE NAMES FROM THE
BORDER OF SB RIGHT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. WHITE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT OR MY COULD OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS THE END AND A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE AND
MOTHER THREE AND FROM COVERING-
SANTANA IN CALIFORNIA AND THEY
SUPPORT AND P. SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. ONE SEVENTY ONE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKER CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED TWELVE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MORGAN A
WHITE WITH THE BURGER EQUITY
ADVOCACY PROJECT AND WE STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. ONE EIGHTY SIX OR MY
COULD OPEN. HIDE WITH THE
NATIONAL HEALTH CLUB PROGRAM
BOB. FIVE THIS THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KATIE AND
YOUR CONTROLS ARE NOW IN
SUPPORT OF ATHLETES SIXTY FIVE
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE FORTY
NINE NEAR MY COULD OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN
EVAN ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA AS A CO
SPONSOR BEEN STELLAR IN TERMS
TO PARTNER DRIVE OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE FIFTY
SIX- MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS LEXI WAIT
WITHIN OUR OWN VOICE NATIONAL
BLACK WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AGENDA CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO YEAR MIKE IS A- HELLO THIS
IS SWATI SHARMA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NAIL SALON
COLLABORATIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR YEAR MIKE IS
A- HELLO MY NAME IS PAIGE
EFFORTS BURKE DELIVERY FIGHT
LACTATION EDUCATION SPECIALIST
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA NINE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EXCEED SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU BYE.
BLIND HUNDRED. YEAR MIKE IS A-
MY NAME IS NOT CALL I'M A NEW
MOTHER OF TWINS AND- I AM FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY FIVE. THANK
YOU OUR MODERATOR- CAN YOU
INDICATE HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE ARE ONLINE WE FOR TAKING
ABOUT TEN MINUTES OF- PUBLIC
TESTIMONY BEYOND THAT
TESTIFYING AND WE HAVE NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION BUT DUCKY
PLEASE INDICATE HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE STILL WAITING TO TESTIFY.
SURE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE NINE
PEOPLE WAITING TO TEST. OKAY
SO- THOSE SEE WHAT CONTRACT GET
THROUGH THOSE- APPRECIATE
PEOPLE'S INTEREST I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT- THERE'S NO FOR
THESE FOR MY POSITION OTHER WE
MAY HEAR PEOPLE TESTIFYING OF
OPPOSITION DEPENDS- SO PLEASE
CONTINUE. AGAIN NAME
WORKSTATION POSITION ONLY. LINE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY NINE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
AFTER LUNCH AND CHAT WITH THE
WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE AND
GENDER TRACTORS LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE YOUR BIKE IS UP. I
APOLOGIZE- LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD UP.
HELLO JANET CARROLL WITH THE
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE
ACTUALLY PROGRAM AFTER SCHOOL
SOCIAL AT UC BERKELEY AND I AM
STRONG SUPPORT ABOUT THE SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR YOUR
MIKE AT THE- HI THIS IS MOLLY
WATCHING CALLING ON BEHALF OF
COURAGE CALIFORNIA AND BLACK
WOMEN'S DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE YOUR MIKE
AT THE- YOUR MEMBERS KATHY
MUSTARD ON BEHALF OF THE FIRST
FIVE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO YEAR MY KIDS OF.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS KENNY
OPERON NO WHICH STRENGTH BASED
COMMUNITY CHANGE IN WILMINGTON
CALIFORNIA I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF S. B. THANK YOU
EXLINE. FIND ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE YOUR MY KIDS UP. HI THIS
IS DIMOND LEE WITHOUT DENTAL
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES AND THE L. A. COUNTY
AIM INITIATIVE AND STRONG
RECORDED AT THE SIXTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
LINE NINETY FOUR YEAR MIKE IS A-
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS LYN
CHRISTY WITH MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCESS MARIN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE
TWO HUNDRED ONE YOUR BIKE IT UP.
ALL RIGHT WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OR POLITICAL BEING OUT
OF FRESNO AND SUPPORTER AND.
THANK YOU NEXT NINE. BLIND
HUNDRED EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HI THIS IS JULIE A BOLD
I'M A NURSE MIDWIFE AT COTTON
BURKE VENTURA CAMERA CHEN HOW.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. BLIND
FAITH OR MY KIDS. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO KEPT ALMOST BASED
COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES IN TO
LOOK. AND I IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AND SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK ANY ADDITIONAL. PEOPLE
THIS WE SHOULD HAVE WENT
THROUGH. WE HAVE ONE PERSON
WAITED GOING TO GO IN THE TO
FOR THAT ONE FOR AND- HOME ON.
LYDALL ONE NINE THREE YOU'RE
LIKE IT'S OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY THE IS FULLY OF LATE
WITH THE WITH TALK INSTITUTE
FOUNDATION OF HOW. PRODUCTS
COULD NOT AND CHUNK AT THE IF I
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE. MISTER WE
HAVE NO FOR COMMENT THAT THING
YOU OKAY THAT'S NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE- I NOT HAVE A LEAD ON.
TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL MOVE
ROOM TO THE GALLERY PUBLIC
GALLERY SAYING NO IN THE PUBLIC
GALLERY. ALEX MOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SAYING AND SEE THE
OF THE KNOWN AT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR PEOPLE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SIXTY FIVE. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THE NEW ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE A
COUPLE COMMENTS COMING ONE
MOMENT PLEASE HOLD WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. OKAY THANK YOU. END OF
LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR
YEAR MIKE IS ABOUT TO THE
OPPOSITION. OPPOSITION TO TALK
ABOUT THE BILL ONE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY OR YOUR MICROPHONE'S.
GALLERY I'M HERE TO REMIND FROM
QUALITY CARE HEALTHCARE SIX
CALIFORNIA I. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. WHITE ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR
MIKE OPEN. I AM FROM QUALITY
HEALTHCARE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH NOW
LET'S BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.I DON'T
SEE. THANKS TO HELP US-
GONZALEZ. YES AT. BUT JUST WHEN
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW
THIS IS BEEN TALKED OUT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL I'M GLAD WE'RE
DOING SOMETHING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I WOULD LOVE TO CO
AUTHOROF THE BILL AS WELL. AND
ALL MOVE THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU BILLS AND MOVE BY
SERRA GONZALEZ THE PREPPY TIME
CENTER RUBIO. YES THANK YOU-
THINK IT CHAIR AND ALSO AND I
THINK THAT THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL I THINK THIS IS BEEN. A
SYSTEMATIC PROBLEM AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS I THINK THIS BILL IS
VERY COMPREHENSIVE AND- IT
TACKLES ALL THE ISSUES THAT
MUST BE. SOLVED AND IT
CONTINUES TO DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT WOMEN OF COLOR. CHILDREN
OF COLOR AND I THINK THAT THIS
IS SUCH AN- EASY. SOLVABLE
PROBLEM IF WE JUST INVEST IT IN
AND THESE ISSUES AND SO ARE
ALSO ON A BEACON. ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AND I URGE EVERYONE. TO
SUPPORT IT. IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE IT REALLY DOES HELP IN
EXPANDING THE RESEARCH AND
GATHERING INFORMATION WE NEED.
IT ALSO EXPANDS THE MEDICAL
CARE WORKFORCE IN AN IMPROVED
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. AND FOR
ALL THESE REASONS I ALSO URGE
AN EYEFUL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO SIR LEYVA. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK-
CENTER SKINNER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND I WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
WHENEVER APPROPRIATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. OKAY
SAYING NONE CENTER SKINNER- I.
TWO ONE THANK YOU FOR READING
THIS BILL FORD- ADDRESSES A LOT
OF VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES- WE-
WE SHOULD BE PROUD IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY THAT OUR
MATERNAL MORTALITY RATE IS
LOWER THAN MOST OTHER STATES-
BUT WE CAN DO EVEN BETTER. AND
SO WE STILL HAVE TO ADDRESS-
THE CONTINUING DISPARITIES IN
OUTCOMES- HAT WE SEE EVEN HERE
IN CALIFORNIA- AND- THIS BILL
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD TO
THAT. SO AGAIN I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANKS SO MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND ALSO
MEMBERS FOR COMMENTS. SO WHILE
THE DATA POINTS TO DISPARITIES
AS WE'VE DISCUSSED FOR UN ALT
ED. MOTHER'S AFRAID OF COLOR
AND ALSO THEIR BABIES. SB SIXTY
FIVE THE BENEFITS IN THAT WILL
SUPPORT ALL PREGNANCIES AND
BIRTHS IN CALIFORNIA BUT IT
WOULD ALSO GIVE US BETTER
INFORMATION AS WAS POINTED OUT
BY- SENATOR RUBIO. TO
UNDERSTAND WHY WE HAVE THESE
DISCIPLINE DISPARITIES. AND SO
THE DATA COLLECTIONS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT. SO IT WILL CLOSE
HOPEFULLY SOME OF THE RACIAL
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST. PREVENT
PREVENTABLE DEATHS IN PRETERM
BIRTHS WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE OKAY. THANKS VERY MUCH
CENTER SKINNER TO THE MOTION IS
BEING MOVED TO FISERV GONZALEZ
DO PASSPORT FOR. THE FIRST HE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE AND
HUMAN SERVICES I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
AND YOU GET SERVICES.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I MELINDA SIDE
MELENDEZ AYE A- ALL RIGHT EIGHT
ITEMS ALL. HI AND SO I. HER
LEYVA LEYVA I. SHE'S ROTH FIVE
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
WIENER HI WIENER HI. EIGHT THE
CURRENT- VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO
WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL
THANKS VERY MUCH OKAY NEXT UP
IS- CENTER MCGUIRE- ITEM NUMBER
TWO THIS IS SB.
EIGHTY MORNING
ACTUALLY LET ME SAY GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS HERE AND I
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU. I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT WONDERFUL WORK ALONG
YOUR STAFF'S FANTASTIC WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WILL BE ACCEPTING
OF COURSE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT CALIFORNIA
TAKES GREAT PRIDE WITH ITS CRAP
PLEASE. COURSE CRABBING IS THE
OLDEST COMMERCIAL FISHERY IN
CALIFORNIA. CATFISH MEN WORK
INCREDIBLY HARD THEIR WORK
HELPS PROP UP OUR RURAL COASTAL
ECONOMIES AND THEY PUT WORLD
RENOWNED HEALTHY FRESH SEAFOOD.
ON OUR DINNER PLATES EACH AND
EVERY YEAR- END SENATOR ROTH
IT'S ONE OF HIS FAVORITES.
THESE FISHERMEN RISK THEIR
LIVES EVERY DAY DOING THE JOBS-
IN THE DANGEROUS AND EVEN LIFE
THREATENING CONDITIONS. IT IS
TIME TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
SAFETY. CODE CONSISTENCY
FLEXIBILITY AND OPPORTUNITY
WHICH THIS BILL WOULD DO. SB
EIGHTY IS THE JOINT COMMITTEES
ON AND ON FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE ANGEL ON THE THIS
BILL. RIGHT TO REMEDY ISSUES
AND CHALLENGES LARGE AND SMALL
RELATED TO CALIFORNIA'S
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE
INDUSTRIES HERE ARE THE
SPECIFICS ON WHAT THIS BILL
WILL DO NUMBER ONE. EIGHT IT
ADDRESSES VARIOUS ISSUES
REGARDING EXCEEDING CRAB SEASON
PRESO PERIODS TO ADDRESS SAFETY
CONCERNS FOR FISHERMEN- AND IT
ALSO BRINGS CONSISTENCY TO
CODE. IT ALLOWS FOR CRAB AND
THE SERRATION. CRAB GETTING
OPTIONS DUE TO THE PRESENCE OF
THE MALL GAS IT. IT ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
COLLECT BIOLOGICAL SAMPLES FROM
COMMERCIAL FISHERIES AND
PROCESSING FACILITIES WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. IT
FACILITATES TRAVEL BY ALLOWING
FOR TISHMAN TO TRANSIT IN
CLOSED OR DELAYS AREAS PROVIDED
THEY USE ELECTRONIC MONITORING
OUT ON THE OCEAN. IT
STREAMLINES THE TRANSFER
PROCESS OF THE DUNGENESS CRAB
VESSEL PERMIT UPON THE SALE.
ENDED THE PRICE A FAIR START
WIN THE CRAB SEASON STARTS. TO
PLAY A PRICE PLY SEVERE START
TO DELAYS ASSOCIATED. WITH THE
RISK. ASSESSMENT MITIGATION
PROGRAM. IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE
RISK OF MARINE LIFE INTEGUMENT
AND FOR CONSISTENCY ESPECIALLY
FOCUS ON WALES. NEARLY ALL OF
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS. AND
MEMBERS IT COMMITTEE CAME FROM
US. FROM THE DUNGEON IS. TASK
FORCE. THIS TASK FOR IS LED.
MAN TO BE AN ADVISER BODY OR
CLEARING HOUSE TASKS REVIEWING
AND EVALUATING THE CRAB FISHERY
MANAGEMENT MEASURES IN
PROVIDING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD WILDLIFE THE JOINT
COMMITTEE N FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE AND THE FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION. THERE ARE
SEVENTEEN COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN
ON THAT BOARD ELECTED BY THEIR
PEERS ALONG WITH ADVISORY BOARD
MEMBERS FROM FISH AND WILDLIFE-
IS WELL SB EIGHTY HAS BROAD
SUPPORT FROM THE INDUSTRY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
AND WORK GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE
MIKE CONNERY WITH US TODAY HE'S
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION AND
LOCUSTS CRICKETS WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY FOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN. AYE
VOTE MISS RICHARD THANKS AGAIN
FOR YOUR WORK. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR MCGUIRE AND APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'VE AYE STAFF THE
AMENDMENTS. NOTES MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON OUR LEAD-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- MIKE
CONROY- FROM PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION AND LUCAS. FREE
RICHEST- SECOND PLEASE BRING
THEM ONLINE WILL BEGIN WITH-
MIKE CONROY. AND EACH OF YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU
A TWO MINUTE WARNING TOTAL
FORMAT ITSELF MIKE IF YOU GO
OVER THAT. AND THAT'S A LITTLE
LESS TIME FOR YEARS- SECOND
THAT'S FIRE. PERFECT UNDERSTOOD
FROM YOU CAN HEAR ME YES I CAN
HEAR YOU PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MIKE CONNERY I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS. SPEAKING SUPPORT
THEM SB EIGHTY BUT THIS BILL
WOULD IMPROVE SAFETY OF
COMMERCIAL FISHING VESSELS AND
KRILOGY BY ALLOWING. THE ENGINE
IS CRAFTED FROM TO SET THEIR
GEAR SIXTY FOUR HOURS BEFORE
THE OPENING OF THE FISHING
SEASON. IT WOULD ALSO IMPROVE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE SEAFOOD
SUPPLY CHAIN BY ALLOWING OUR
STATE AGENCIES TO PURSUE AN
ADMINISTRATION PROGRAM
PRODUCTION THIS CRAB IN THE
VENDOR DIMOCK ACCIDENTS WHICH
WOULD OTHERWISE KEEP THE POLICE
TIED TO THE DOCTOR. AND DEPRIVE
DEPENDENT COMMUNITIES OF THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF THE
DECRYPTED STRING WHICH IS OFTEN
THE STATE'S MOST. VALUABLE
FISHERY. AS YOU KNOW IN A TO
THE- FISHERMAN'S. IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVER NINETEEN AND THEN
THE COMMERCIAL FISHERY OF OUR
STATE HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH
SIGNATURE ACT. AND HARDSHIP
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
WHAT THE LOSS OF MOBILE FISHING
VESSEL TO LIVE ON THE WEST
COAST IN RECENT YEARS. TAKING
ACTIONS THAT CAN IMPROVE
SAFETY. IS PARAMOUNT. BUT
INCREASE PRESO AREA FOR THE D.
CRABTREE IN THE CENTRAL COAST
REGION CALIFORNIA WILL ENSURE
THAT FISHERMEN ARE PART OF THE
FLEXIBILTY. TO DEPLOY THEIR
PITCHING IN RESPONSE TO A
VARIABLE WEATHER CONDITIONS.
THIS INCREASE FLEXIBILITY WILL
IMPROVE SAFETY. AND EVEN SAVE
LIVES. SB EIGHTY PROVIDES
SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN VETTED
AND RECOMMENDED TO US. BY THE
JUDGES CRAP TASK FORCE A
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED BODY
TASKED TO AMONGST OTHER THINGS.
ADVISE THE LEGISLATURE. THIS
BILL GREATLY BENEFITS VETERANS
OF THE PROVIDE THE FLEXIBILITY
CONSISTENCY AND SAFETY THE
NEED. THAT ALSO HAS BROAD%
SUPPORT ACROSS INDUSTRY AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE BY
ON. SB EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NOW CAN WE HAVE- LUCAS-
FREE. YES GOOD CHAIR PAN INTO
MY NAME BECAUSE FOR ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY CAN
CAN SPEAKING INTO OF SB EIGHTY.
OVER THE FIVE YEARS P. AND G.
PART CLOSELY WITH THE COURT.
DUNGENESS GRESHAM MANAGE AND-
SUPPORT OF THE PURCHASED THE
DONE CRAB TRAPS FOR WHICH AND
WE ARE UNDER THE ON GOING OF
THE MANAGER BODY CRITIC INCLUDE
THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD THE
TASK FORCE RECOMMENDATION TO
ENABLE THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN
ADMINISTRATION OPTIONS IN
RESPONSE TO ELEVATED DOMOIC
ACID LEVELS. EIGHT INCREASES IN
CURRENT CONSIDERED IRRELEVANT
DEMO LIKE AFTER LEVEL THAN THE
EXAMPLE OF MANY CLIMATE DRIVEN
OCEAN CHANGES IMPACTING
FISHERIES AND OCEAN ECOSYSTEMS
THEY DEPEND ON. IN RESPONSE TO
THESE EXTREMES MANAGERS NEED
MORE ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT TOOLS
LIKE EVISCERATION OPTION IS
OPTION WILL GIVE MANAGERS THE
ABILITY TO MITIGATE IMPACTS
DOMOIC ACID THAT LAYS ON THE
COMMERCIAL DUNGENESS CRAB
FISHERY. THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
ALSO BELIEVE IMPROVED DATA
COLLECTION SCIENTISTS CRITICAL
TO EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO
CHANGING OCEAN INDUSTRY
CONDITIONS SB EIGHTY SAMPLING
REQUIREMENT IN CALIFORNIA WILL
MERE SAMPLING APARTMENTS IN
OREGON AND WASHINGTON AND LEAD
TO BETTER INFORMATION TO
IMPROVE CERTAINTY IN STOCK
ASSESSMENTS AND SUPPORT MORE
ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT DECISIONS
UNDER CHANGING OCEAN
CONDITIONS. WE APPRECIATE
CENTER MAGUIRE'S CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB EIGHTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY THANK YOU NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
AT HOME GO TO THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SAY KNOWN AT THE PUBLIC
GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THING ON ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR PEOPLE
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB. EIGHTY AGAIN
ITS NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BURCON IN. OF S. B.
EIGHTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND-
SECOND AGAIN ONE THING. ZERO
AND MISTER CHAIR I SHOW NO
COMMENT COMING FOR OKAY THANK
YOU NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY WE DO NOT
HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
WHO IS GOING TO GIVE. A FORMAL
TESTIMONY SO THAT WILL MOVE TO
THE PUBLIC GALLERY- SAYING
KNOWING THAT THE PUBLIC GALLERY
TO FIND OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHTY
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SAY NO WITNESSES THERE
LET'S MOVE NOW TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINE SO AGAIN
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR PEOPLE WISHING WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. EIGHTY.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. BACK COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE TEN ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIR
I SHOW NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- CENTER ROTH. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
FACILITATING THE AVAILABILITY
OF KRIPALU E. IN INLAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN THE
FUTURE AND I WILL MOVE- THE
BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE POINT
IN TIME OKAY. BILL BE MOVED IT
FROM THE TIME I CENTER OFFICER
EGGMAN. THANK YOU. AND MR I
JUST ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING ON THIS IS
BECAUSE NOT ONLY DOES THE CRAP
INDUSTRY SUPPORT A LOT OF THE
COASTAL COMMUNITIES. IT
SUPPORTS SO MANY OF THE NON
PROFITS IN MY DISTRICT AND
AROUND PARTS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ITH CRAB FEEDS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SEASON
WHERE THERE'S BARS IN THE IN
THE IN THE MONTHS WE KNOW THAT
MEANS CRAPPIES ARE COMING. AND
A LOT OF OUR SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS AND NON PROFITS-
REALLY MISSED- ALL OF THE-
OPPORTUNITIES THIS YEAR. THE
LAST TWO YEARS FOR CRAP SO WE
ARE. RIGHT I WAS GOING TO MOVE
IT BUT I WILL- DISABILITY VOTE
I'VE BEEN THIS BILL COMES UP.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
FROM SEEING NONE- SO REQUIRE
ONLY THANK YOU ALSO FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
I'LL TELL YOU MY FAMILY ME MY
CONSTITUENTS THAT WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. ONE OF THE BIG
EVENTS THAT I LIKE TO ATTEND IS
THE JAPANESE AMERICAN CITIZENS
LEAGUE. CRAB FEED IN AS WELL AS
OTHER CRAB FEEDS AS WELL. AND
SO THE BILL BILITY OF MORE CRAB
MEAT- IS GOING TO BE. QUITE
WELCOME. BUT THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF MISTER CHAIR AT ANY
GIVEN SECURE THANK YOU AND YOUR
TEAM UP FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
WENT INTO THIS. I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH CENTER EGGMAN
REGARDS TO THOSE CRAB SEASON
HOW CRITICAL THEY ARE LEGALLY
RAISING. MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ACROSS THE STATE FOR VERY
WORTHY NONPROFITS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT THE CENTER ROTH FOR THE
MOTION. IN JUST FINALLY WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU THE DUNGEONS CRAP
TASK FORCE. THEY HAVE A
THANKLESS JOB. THERE BEHIND THE
SCENES. WADING THROUGH SOME
REALLY SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
OVER THESE PAST YEARS WITH THE
MOWER ACID. IN IT IS BEEN
ROUGH- AS WELL AS WELL
ENTANGLEMENT WHEN I WANT TO SAY
IS. THIS INDUSTRY STEPPED UP.
MISTER CHAIR- AT ITS PEAK AT
NEARLY SIXTY WHALES ENTANGLED
LAST YEAR ONE- AND THEY HAVE
DONE AN AMAZING JOB SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. WORKING ON
THAT ISSUE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU THE DUNGEONS CARE TASK
FORCE THE PACIFIC COAST.
FEDERATION- THE CCD OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION. AND
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WHO HAS
JUMPED IN FEET FIRST TO MAKE
THIS WORK AND VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THEM. THAT WE FORMALLY. ASKED
NOT TO LET THIS BILL FOUNDER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
OKAY BOY I KNOW WE SHOULD LOOK
AT OUT THAT. RIGHT THE MOST
IT'S BEEN MOVE BY SERRA TO
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FOR AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE OF. CONSULT PLEASE
THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AM I
LINDA'S EIGHT BY EGGMAN RIGHT
AND SALAS HI GONZALEZ I GREW OF
HER TADO. THE HI LEYVA HI LIMA.
ROTH ALL RIGHT ROTH RUBIO HI
RUBIO AYE WIENER. WIENER. WHAT
ROLE IS EIGHT ZERO POTENTIAL
CALL THANK YOU. RIGHT NEXT
ITEMS ITEM NUMBER THREE SB TWO
TWO NINE BY CENTER DOLLY
WELCOME. OKAY. GOOD MORNING-
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING SP TWO TWO NINE
WHICH IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL
TO PROVIDE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS GRANT FUNDS TO OUR
SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO OUR STUDENTS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY COVERT
NINETEEN CLOSER SCHOOLS SCHOOL
CLOSURES BY MINUTES MAKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THE
LEAD AGENCY AN ESTABLISHED AS A
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF. FOR THE FOR
THE- MINUTES WORKING WITH ME ON
THE MINUTES JUST THIS WEEK IN A
REPORT ON THE STRUGGLES OF OUR
SCHOOLS SHOULD SCHOOL CHILDREN
IN CARE CALIFORNIA WAS RELEASED
IT STATED STUDENTS IN BOSTON
THIS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
ARE EXPERIENCING THE PAINFUL
LOSS OF CONNECTION WITH THEIR
PEERS TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF
AND A SERIES LOSS OF LEARNING
THAT WILL HAVE LIFELONG
CONSEQUENCES IF NOT ADDRESSED.
I WITNESSED THIS WITH MY OWN
DAUGHTER. SHE WILTED WHEN SHE
WAS FORCED TO DO DISTANCE
LEARNING. THIS FUNDING IT THIS
FUNDING IS CRITICAL NECESSARY
TO BEGIN THE AND ADDRESS THE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC ON OUR
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH. SCHOOL
COUNSELORS NURSES SOCIAL
WORKERS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS. ARE
FREQUENTLY THE FIRST TO SEE
CHILDREN WHO ARE SICK STRESSED
AND TRAUMATIZED ESPECIALLY LOW
INCOME DISTRICTS. THE STUDY WAS
RELEASED BY THE FAIR HEALTH
FOUNDATION THAT CLAIMS. FOR
INTER THE CLAIMS FOR
INTERNATIONAL SELF HARM AS A
PERCENTAGE OF THE MEDICAL
CLAIMS IN THE AGES FROM
THIRTEEN TO EIGHTEEN AGE GROUP
INCREASED FROM NINETY. POINT 7%
IN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY COMPARED
TO MARCH. TWO NINE TO NINETEEN.
THE INCREASE WAS EVEN LARGER
COMPARING APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
TWO APRIL TWENTY NINETEEN
NEARLY DOUBLED NINETY NINE
POINT EIGHT PERCENT. DAA SHOWS
THAT THE PRESENCE OF SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
NOT ONLY IMPROVES OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS BUT ALSO CAN IMPROVE
THE OVERALL SCHOOL SAFETY.
STUDIES FURTHER FURTHER SHOW
THAT CHILDREN. YOUNG CHILDREN
SHOW MORE CLEANING THIS
DISTURBS SLEEP NIGHTMARES POOR
APPETITE. INATTENTIVENESS
INSIGNIFICANT SEPARATION
PROBLEMS THIS FUNDING STREAM
WILL HELP OUR SCHOOLS. CHILDREN
THROUGHOUT THE NEXT PHASE OF
THEIR LIVES THANK YOU AND I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- CENTER DOLLY I DO NOT
HAVE A LEAD SUPPORT- THE
WITNESS TO PROVIDE FORMAL
TESTIMONY SO WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND- MOVED TO ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. WILL
BEGIN IN THE PUBLIC GALLERY
AGAIN THE SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
TWO NINE SEEN ON THE PUBLIC
GALLERY LET'S MOVE THE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN KNOWN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES- FOR WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO TWO NINE. THANK
YOU MR CARE OR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TWO NINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE. BUTTON ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME OKAY- WILL
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION- WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSED- RIGHT TESTIMONY. IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO TWO NINE
SCHOOL THEN MOVED TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- UP THE
PUBLIC PUBLIC GALLERY SAYING NO
ONE IN THE PUBLIC GALLERY IN TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO ROOM
TWO TWO NINE LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SAYING NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELEPHONIC LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE ALLOW
WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO TWO NINE-
TO COME ON THE LINE. AGAINST
NAME WORKSTATION POSITIONALLY.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
U. S. B. TWO TWO NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE TEN ZERO.
AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ONE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH THEIR LIFE AND.
FIFTY ONE
MORE MOMENT PLEASE OKAY. THE
AIRLINE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. OKAY PLEASE
BEGIN. WHY TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MAIL. I APOLOGIZE
MISTER CHAIR THERE SEEMS TO BE
NO ONE ON THE LINE. OKAY VERY
GOOD ALL RIGHT. ACTUALLY BEFORE
WE BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE-
I WANT TO WELCOME CENTER LET
ALONE- WELCOME AND- THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US OF YOUR JOIN US
REMOTELY. AND SO FIRST OF ALL I
WANT YOU TO INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND THEN ALSO INDICATE IF
THERE'S ANY STAFF WITH YOU IF
THERE ARE THE NAME OF THE STAFF
PERSON WHO'S WITH YOU SO CENTER
LAMONT. THANK YOU CHAIR SENATOR
LEE MON I MEAN THE DISTRICT
OFFICE AND I HAVE BENJAMIN. SEN
A STAFF MEMBER WITH ME. OKAY
THANK YOU CEREMONY AND I THINK-
YOU PROBABLY UP RATE QUITE
FAMILIAR BUT JUST QUICKLY THE
INSTRUCTIONS ARE TO MUTE YOUR
DEVICE. WHEN YOU ARE TESTIFYING
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO SEEK
FEEDBACK THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
THE CEREMONY ALL RIGHT NOW
LET'S BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
ON SB TWO TWO NINE TO THE
COMMITTEE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SIR RUBIO. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I YOU KNOW I WANT
TO COMMEND MR DOLLY THE GREAT
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I UNDERSTAND WHY HE'S
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AS A
FORMER TEACHER IT THERE REALLY
IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
PUT A LOT OF FOCUS ON I KNOW-
AS TEACHERS AND WE'RE A LOT OF
THINGS FALL ON OUR SHOULDERS
YOU KNOW THEY WERE EXPECTED TO
BE THERAPISTS NURSES SOCIAL
WORKERS EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE
NOT QUALIFIED TO DO. AND I
THINK THAT- SOME PEOPLE ASSUME
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE A
SEAMLESS TRANSITION FOR
CHILDREN COMING OUT OF COBIT
ISOLATION INTO OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS BUT YESTERDAY I HEARD A
STORY FROM ONE OF THE STUDENTS
AND THAT IS THAT THIS LITTLE
GIRL HAD BEEN PLAYING BY
HERSELF OUT IN THE PLAYGROUND
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE BACK EVEN
THOUGH OTHER THEIR PEERS ARE
BACK. BUT SHE STILL HAS THE
TRAUMA OF FEELING THAT IF SHE
PLAYS WITH KIDS TEXAS KIDS THAT
HER LIFE IS IN DANGER SO THAT
REALLY OPENED MY EYES AS TO HOW
DEEP ROOTED THE TRAUMA IS GOING
TO BE EVEN AFTER THEY COME BACK
AND WE ASSUME THAT IT'S QUOTE
UNQUOTE NORMAL BUT THEY'RE
STILL DEALING WITH THAT FEAR
THAT FOR THE LAST YEAR WE'VE
INSTILLED IN THEM ABOUT SOCIAL
ISOLATION AND DISTANCE SCENE
AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT COMES
WITH YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED LAST YEAR BUT- I
JUST WANTED O SAY THANK YOU
TO. TO THE AUTHOR FOR THINKING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE CERTAINLY WE
CAN USE HELP IN THE SCHOOL
pSYSTEMS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
COMMITTEE. THE NINE- SIR DOLLY
I JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
APPRECIATE- YOUR TESTIMONY
TALKING ABOUT- NOT ONLY
EXPERIENCES WITNESS BUT- YOU
SEEN WITH YOUR OWN FAMILY. MAKE
NOTE THAT- I TO THE FATHER AND
PEDIATRICIAN- THE ALSO SEEN THE
STRESSES ON ON- ON CHILDREN AS
WELL- INCLUDING I'VE TWO
CHILDREN TO ATTENDING SCHOOL.
AND THE CHALLENGES THEY'RE
FACING AS WELL- I KNOW WE HAD
TO HAVE SEVERAL DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH
DAY PRE SHEET THAT YOU'VE PUT
FORTH YOUR OWN AS WELL- FOR US
TO CONSIDER- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THE YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I PER THE CALL FROM A-
I WANT TO SAY THAT TIME. I'VE
NEVER DONE THIS BEFORE NEVER
ASKED FOR. A BIG BUDGET ASK.
BUT I WITNESSED IT WITH MY
DAUGHTER AND IT WAS PAINFUL.
AND WE DON'T KNOW WITH OUR
SOCIETY'S NEVER BEEN THROUGH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW. WE NEED
PEOPLE WE NEED EACH OTHER AT
THE END OF THE DAY- WHEN I
WATCHED- MY DAUGHTER ROSLYN
JUST WILL BECAUSE- EVEN FAMILY
MEMBERS WERE WE WERE SEPARATED
AND- SO. I'M GIVING THIS A SHOT
AT SOMETHING NEW FOR ME I
DIDN'T ASK FOR LEAVE IT IS I
KNOW WE'RE THE TIME FRAMES THAT
WE HAVE IN MEETINGS ALL DAY
WE'RE JUST A TWENTY TOGETHER
MISTER CHAIRMAN. SO I WAS
RESPECT FOR YOUR TIME BUT I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF SUPPORT
FOR THIS AND THERE'S MANY
PROPOSALS OUT THERE- BUT I I'M
I'M GONNA BE ON BOARD WITH
TRYING TO HELP- THE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND- THOSE. I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE WHERE. THERE'S YOU KNOW
SINGLE PARENTS WERE THEY WERE.
NOT ABLE TO GO TO WORK OR IF
THEY WERE ABLE TO GO TO WORK
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE CHILDREN
WE WEREN'T IN THAT SITUATION
AND I SAW. FIRSTHAND WHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF SUPPORT. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY IS OUR MOTION I
SEE- MOTION FROM CENTER ROTH-
AT STAND UP FIRST SO. MISSION
FROM SERA OFFICE DO PASSES
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION. A CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CAN BY HAND I AM.
SIDE MELENDEZ. EIGHT HI. IT AYE
CONSOLE. HI GONZALEZ I'D GROWTH
HER TADO. LEYVA LIMON. SENATE
REALLY MULLIN SP TWO TWO NINE
HI. LIMON HI ROTH ALL RIGHT
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE. SEVEN
OKAY. TO THE CURRENT ROLE AS
EIGHT ZERO- WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BECAUSE ALEX
RIGHT- THE NEXT UP IS ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FIVE NINETEEN BY
SENATOR WIENER. HE WANTED TO
THREE DESK YES THANK YOU. IT IS
AGAIN. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES- AND I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING- THE
CHAIR AND- THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US MEANS BILL. AND
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED ON PAGE
SIX OF ANALYSIS. ARE CALLING
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETEEN.
DECRIMINALIZE THE POSSESSION
AND PERSONAL USE. VARIOUS.
PSYCHEDELIC SUBSTANCES. INSIDE
BEEN- SERVICEMEN INDIA MAY LST
IN GMC MASKELYNE AND I'VE
GAINED A LIMITED TO PEOPLE AGES
TWENTY ONE AND OLDER. HI IN
ADDITION TO ENCOURAGE CITY FOR
USE AND REDUCE HARM THE BILL
ALSO DECRIMINALIZE IS. DRUG
TESTING KITS AND PERMITS THE
POSSESSION OF PARAPHERNALIA TO
USE THE PSYCHEDELIC SUBSTANCES
SB FIVE NINETEEN WILL ALSO
CONVENE AN EXPERT WORKING GROUP
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- TASKED WITH DEVELOPING
RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE FOR POTENTIAL
FUTURE REGULATION REGULATION OF
LEGAL ACCESS TO THESE
SUBSTANCES IN A MANNER THAT
CITY RESPONSIBLE AND EQUITABLE.
THIS LEGISLATION IS COSPONSORED
BY TWO ORGANIZATIONS THAT. HELP
AND WORK WITH COMBAT VETERANS.
TO HELP THEM ACCESS SIGNALED
TREATMENT. FOR PTSD DEPRESSION
AND OTHER MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS WHERE THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO ACHIEVE SUCCESS.
THROUGH THE VA WITH OTHER
TREATMENTS. OUR COLORS THIS
LEGISLATION- IS ONE STEP MOVING
AWAY FROM THE FAILED WAR ON
DRUGS. THE WAR ON DRUGS HAS
BEEN ABJECT FAILURE. BECAUSE IT
IS BASED ON THE FALSE BELIEF
THE FALSE NOTION THAT
CRIMINALIZING PEOPLE ARRESTING-
INCARCERATING THEM FOR
POSSESSING FOR USING DRUGS-
WILL SOMEHOW DETER USE THAT
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY IT HAS
DONE NEITHER I AND SAID WE HAVE
SPEND TRILLIONS IN THE LAST
HALF CENTURY ON THE WAR ON
DRUGS. MORE PEOPLE ARE USING
DRUGS NOW- THERE'S MORE
ADDICTION THERE ARE MORE-
OVERDOSES SOME TALKING ABOUT
DRUGS AND GENERALLY NOT.
PSYCHEDELICS AND- BUT WE HAVE
BUSTED TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND WE
NEED TO MOVE TOWARDS A MORE
HEALTH BASED APPROACH I AM
BRINGING SB FIVE NINETEEN
BEFORE YOU TODAY COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE WE NEED TO CHANGE OUR
RESPONSE TO SUBSTANCE USE AND
BECAUSE THESE PSYCHEDELIC
SUBSTANCES ARE ALREADY BEING
USED TODAY BY CALIFORNIANS FOR
THEIR HEALING POTENTIAL- AND
MICHAEL AND OTHERWISE THEY'RE
BEING USED TODAY I THINK
SOMETIMES PEOPLE HEAR ABOUT
DECRIMINALIZATION AND THEY
THINK IT'S GOING TO SOMEHOW
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE TO USE
STRUCTURE INCREASE DRUG USE OR
MAKE DRUGS MORE ATTRACTIVE-
THAT IS NOT TRUE- THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE. FOR THAT- WE KNOW
THAT BANNING AND CRIMINALIZING
AND TAKING A CARCERAL APPROACH
TO DRUGS PEOPLE STILL USE THAT
THEY STILL USE IT A LOT I SAW
THE QUESTION BEFORE US TODAY.
WHATEVER ONE'S VIEWS. AB THIS
ABOUT SITE- THIS ABOUT DRUGS.
THE QUESTION BEFORE US TODAY IT
SHOULD BE CONTINUED TO ARREST
AND INCARCERATE PEOPLE FOR
POSSESSING AND USING THESE
DRUGS- WHATEVER ONE THINKS OF A
PARTICULAR SUBSTANTIVE IF YOU
LIKE IT OR DON'T LIKE IT OR- OR
THINK IT'S A PROBLEM OR NOT A
PROBLEM. THAT'S THE QUESTION
SHOULD WE BE ARRESTING AND
INCARCERATING PEOPLE FOR HAVING
FOR POSSESSING DRUGS THIS BILL
DOES NOT DECRIMINALIZE SELLING.
IT'S ABOUT POSSESSION AND USE.
AND SO IT'S TIME TO BRING THIS
YEAR'S INTO THE LIGHT SO WE CAN
HAVE A MORE SENSIBLE
CONVERSATION ABOUT C. FOR USE.
OF THE PSYCHEDELICS AND DISPEL
MYTHS. ABOUT DECRIMINALIZATION
IN RECENT YEARS AND WE AND
CALIFORNIA IS NOT- WE'RE NOT
THE FIRST YEAR. IN RECENT YEARS
VARIOUS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVING KNOWLEDGE THAT THE CREW
THAT CRIMINALIZATION- DOES NOT
WORK IN MANY CITIES INCLUDING
SANTA CRUZ IN OAKLAND- AS WELL
AS WASHINGTON DC IN SOMERVILLE
MASSACHUSETTS. OF ALL MOVE
TOWARDS DECRIMINALIZATION OF
PSYCHEDELICS THIS PAST NOVEMBER
OREGON VOTERS PASSED TWO BALLOT
MEASURES WIND DECRIMINALIZED
POSSESSION OF A HUGE SWATH OF
DRUGS GOING WELL WELL WELL
BEYOND PSYCHEDELICS. AND THEN A
SEPARATE MEASURE AUTHORIZED A
MOVE TOWARDS- PSILOCYBIN
ASSISTED THERAPY PROGRAM OVER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS. OTHER
COUNTRIES LIKE PORTUGAL HAVE
ALSO SUCCESSFULLY
DECRIMINALIZED THE POSSESSION
AND PERSONAL USE OF ALL
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. WHILE
OPPONENTS TO DECRIMINALIZATION
AT THE TIME ARGUED THAT
PORTUGAL'S APPROACH WOULD BE
DETRIMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH DRUG
OVERDOSES IN H. I. R. THE WILL
BE DETRIMENTAL TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. WHAT IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENS IS A DRUG OVERDOSES HIV
RATES HAVE PLUMMETED SINCE
PORTUGAL IMPLEMENTED THAT
POLICY. IN TWO THOUSAND ONE.
HUNDRED ADDITION THERE'S BEEN
NO INDICATION OF INCREASED USE
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE WHAT IS OUR
POPULATIONS OF THE ARGUMENTS
FOR HEARING FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THIS BILL. HAVE
BEEN DISPROVEN. OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. HI THIS BILL REFER YOU
AS I MENTIONED IS A FROM TO DO.
ALSO TO BE CLEAR MY PERSONAL
VIEW IS WE NEED TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION TOWARDS BROADER DRUG
DECRIMINALIZATION BUT THAT IS
pBILL. IS ONE STOP. ON BROWN
COMMUNITIES ARE ALREADY USING
THESE SUBSTANCES TO HEAL OUR
VETERANS- TO TREAT PEOPLE
SUFFERING FROM TRAUMA AND HAVE
BEEN USED AS A SACRAMENT AND
SPIRITUAL OR RELIGIOUS
PRACTICES. FOR CENTURIES
INCLUDING IN THIS COUNTRY AMONG
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
LET'S BRING THIS ACTIVITY OUT
OF THE SHADOWS AND ENSURE WE
ARE HELPING ENCOURAGE SAFER
USE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE- WITH ME. BY PHONE TO
TESTIFY TODAY OR JOSE MARTINEZ
WHO WAS AN ARMY VETERAN WITH
THE HERO CARDS PROJECTS ONE OF
OUR SPONSORS. AND DR ROBERT
GRANT A UCSF PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE AND A PSYCHEDELIC DRUG
RESEARCHER THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU SIR WIENER
AND AGAIN- FREESHEET- YOU KNOW
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS- JUST TO
CLARIFY WHICH WITNESSES
TESTIFYING FIRST THOUGHT THE
FIRST WITNESS WILL BE JOSE
MARTINEZ OUR ARMY VETERAN WITH
HER F COURSE PROJECT THE
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON A
JOSE MARTINEZ AND THEN- DR
ROBERT GRANT- TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT A REMINDER TO THE
WITNESSES YOU HAVE- TWO MINUTES
APIECE OR TOTAL FOUR MINUTES
BETWEEN BOTH OF YOU. SO THE
FIRST PERSON GOES OVER THAT
COMES OUT THE SECOND PERSON'S
TIME- SO IT'S PRESENTED. AS A
MARTINEZ AS YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY APOLOGIES- WE
ACTUALLY THE IT'S A- WE HAD TO
SWITCH- THE VETERAN- IT IS-
JESSE GOALS JUST. YES MISTER
MARTINEZ TESTIFIED IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE RIGHT I SORRY AND
ACTUALLY I'M JUST EAGLE MY
NOTES HERE BUT I THOUGHT YOU
MAY BE ANOTHER SWITCH POLITICS
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING ON JESSE
GOLD- MODERATE PLEASE BRING ON
JESSE GOLD AND DR. ROBERT GRANT
WILL BEGIN WITH JESSE GOLD. CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK. JESSE YES
PLEASE BEGIN. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JESSE GOAL
AND I'M THE FOUNDER OF THE
NONPROFIT HER- CARDS PROJECT
WHICH CONNECTS MILITARY
VETERANS THE PSYCHEDELIC
THERAPIES AND IS THE CO
SPONSORS OF SB FIVE ONE NINE. I
AM AN ARMY RANGER VETERAN WITH
THREE COMBAT DEPLOYMENTS TO
AFGHANISTAN OF THE
NONCOMMISSIONED OFFICER IN
CHARGE OF THIRTY PLUS
INDIVIDUALS BOTH AT HOME AND
OVERSEAS IN COMBAT SITUATIONS.
LIKE A QUICKLY SHARE A FEW
WORDS FROM A VETERAN WHO
REACHED OUT FOR MY HEALTH A FEW
YEARS BACK HIS EMAIL STARTED
WITH BALLING. I DID NOT DIE IN
WAR I WAS DYING WHEN I RETURN
HOME. THIS INDIVIDUAL HAD TRIED
EVERYTHING TO BE A HAD TO OFFER
FOR YEARS INCLUDING A VARIETY
OF THERAPIES AND COUNTLESS
MEDICATIONS TO LITTLE AVAIL. HE
WAS AT HIS ROPES AND
CONTEMPLATING SUICIDE. FIVE
YEARS AGO MY ORGANIZATIONS ON
THIS MATTER AND TO REPUTABLE
PSYCHEDELIC TREATMENT CENTER IN
PERU. HE IS NOW THRIVING AND
STAR A COPY BUSINESS. THIS IS
JUST ONE OF THOUSANDS OF
SIMILAR STORIES MY OWN STORY
WAS NO DIFFERENT. PSYCHEDELIC
THERAPY SAVED MY LIFE. IT IS
EFFECTIVE IT IS SAFE. WHAT IS
UNJUSTLY STIGMATIZED. AND I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ONE THING IN
THE STORY. A U. S. LETTER AND
HAD TO GO TO PERU. TO GET
EFFECTIVE MENTAL HEALTH CARE. I
DID NOT DIE IN WAR I WAS DYING
WHEN I RETURN HOME. THIS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA AND THIS BILL WE ARE
DISCUSSING TODAY WILL BE A
HISTORIC STEP IN RIGHTING THESE
WRONGS. AND ALLOWING ACCESS TO
EFFECTIVE TOOLS WITHOUT HEARING
INCRIMINATION FOR THE VETERAN
POPULATION AS WELL AS OTHER
STRUGGLING COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. I STRONGLY URGE THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE ONE
NINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NOW LET'S BRING ON DR
ROBERT GRANT- YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
TWO MINUTES AND FOURTEEN
SECONDS. THAT'S A LOOK AT YOUR
LOCAL TIME- DR GRANT. HELLO MY
NAME IS DR ROBERT M. GRANT I AM
A PHYSICIAN SCIENTIST AND A
FATHER. THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IN THE UNITED STATES ITS
PANDEMIC SUICIDE AT THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN
ADULTS BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TWENTY FORTY FOUR. WELL HEALTH
ORGANIZATION FROM THE
DEPRESSION IS THE LEADING CAUSE
OF DISABILITY WORLDWIDE. ABOUT
ONE IN TWENTY PEOPLE HAD PTSD
IN THE U. S. EVERY YEAR.
EXISTING THERAPIES FOR
DEPRESSION PTSD OR ONLY
MINIMALLY IMPACTED. ORLANDO
DEPRESSANTS TAKE MANY WEEKS TO
TAKE A FAX AND THEY HAVE SIDE
EFFECTS. LESS THAN HALF OF
TREATED PEOPLE RESPOND AND LESS
THAN A QUARTER RESPOND FOR MORE
THAN A YEAR. CHECK IT OUT
ANDERSON'S ARE READILY
AVAILABLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
PROXIMITY THIRTY MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE UNITED STATES HAVE USED
PSYCHEDELICS AND LYFT TIMES.
ABOUT ONE MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES USE SECOND ALEX
AND PAST YEAR. ALEX CAN BE
TRANSFORMATIVE IN THE TREATMENT
OF DEPRESSION PTSD SUICIDALITY
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
THESE MEDICINES ARE NOT USED
DALY. RATHER SHORT COURSES OF
PSYCHEDELICS ARE HEALING.
HEALING IS DURABLE FOR YEARS.
ENTER EXAMPLES MDMA IS HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE FOR PTSD AS SHOWN IN
TWO SIX CLINICAL TRIALS NOW
COMPLETED AND PUBLISHED. IN THE
ACTIVE INGREDIENT THE MUSHROOMS
AND LSD ARE USED TO TREAT
DEPRESSION IN THE SETTING OF
LIFE THREATENING YOUNG. PLANTS
CONTAINING THE M. PROVIDE THE
RELIEF QUESTION INTO. AND HELP
BUILD COMMITTEE SPIRIT. I'M
LOOKING IS USED TO TREAT HOPE
USE. PSYCHEDELICS ARE GENERALLY
SAFE. SEVERAL OF THE
PSYCHEDELICS ARE TRIED TO HAVE
NOTED THAT THE POTENTIAL AT ALL
SUCH AS LSD PSILOCYBIN I'M
LOOKING. ALL COMPOUND THERE
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL. IT
DETECTED A LETTER USED TO TREAT
SUCH USE THIS WHICH ARE ALL
PENNED IN OUR COMMUNITY.
RESEARCH ON PSYCHEDELICS
CUMBERSOME AND THE MANY REASONS
FOR THIS WHICH WE CAN DISCUSS.
AND THERE'S SCANT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR RESEARCH PARTICIPANTS. THE
CRIMINALIZATION AND THE AND THE
WORKING GROUP TO LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR REGULATED PLEASE
PLEASE WRAP ACTUALLY IS THANK.
THIS WILL TRANSFORM INCLUDED
CRISIS HE WENT TO COMMUNITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
NINETEEN WILL MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC GALLERY. SEEN ON
APPROACHING THE MIKE FROM THE
PUBLIC GALLERY WAS MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN KNOWN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSESWHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETEEN-
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION
ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER CARE FOR
COMMON IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE
NINETEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO BACK COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND WIND TWO HUNDRED I
APOLOGIZE WHY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
IT HELLO HELLO MY NAME IS
MONICA CONTAINER I'M HERE WITH
BLACK BURKE- AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETEEN
THAT WILL BE CRIMINALIZING. ON
AN EXTENSION THANK YOU- OKAY
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
LINE. WINE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE LIKE IT'S OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHANE NORRIE-
THE FROM MY NATURE OF BOARD
MEMBER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB FIVE NINETEEN THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS UP.
CAN YOU PLEASE SHARE THE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
WHITE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. MY NAME
PAYING GOLD TEAM I'M A RETIRED
LIEUTENANT. CALIFORNIA IN FACT
THE DIRECTOR OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION PARTNERSHIP
FONG THE COURT. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. ONE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHANCELLOR'S
MOMENT HELLO MARGINALIZED
ASSEMBLY FOR THAT COUNTRY HELLO
TRYING TO JONES IS B. NINETEEN
WHICH WILL DECRIMINALIZE
LIMITATION THANK YOU
GOVERNMENTS AND THANK THANK YOU
NEXT. LINE TWO HUNDRED SEVEN
YOUR MY KIDS UP. HI MY NAME IS
LABOR CAMP DIRECTOR MIGHT TELL
ON BEHALF OF OUR TO GO PLUS
WHICH SHOULD THE FACT OF AT
CRIED MY THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LIVE HER TWENTY NINE
YOUR IT'S OKAY. YES MY NAME IS
COLIN WELLS I'M THE FOUNDER OF
BETTER WALKING TALK AND I AM
AND SO OF SB FIVE ONE NINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT. LIGHT A ONE. EIGHT YOUR
KIDS UP. GREETINGS MY NAME IS
JAMES MCCARTY I AM THE CO
FOUNDER OF THE PSYCHEDELIC
SMALL BUSINESSES ADMINISTRATION
I AM THE CO FOUNDER OF THE TO
CRIMINALIZE NATURE SAN
FRANCISCO AND I AM THE OWNER OF
THE STREET ROOM SHOP. FULL
SUPPORT BOB SB FIVE NINETY
THANK DAY THANK YOU EXLINE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS WITHHELD AWESOME HI I
AM HEY HOMES HERE IN THE
PRESENT IN THE OF TO
CRIMINALIZE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF COURSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS PAUL BREEDEN. THE LAWN
CARE WITH YOU COMPLY SAN
FRANCISCO ONLINE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETEEN
THANK YOU THANKS LINE. WHAT
LINE OF ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI
AND DR KELLY MCCORMICK WITH TH
KERN CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
WHY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
YOU'RE MY COULD UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR LARRY
NORRIS I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
AND EUGENICS RESEARCH
INTEGRATION EDUCATION ELEVEN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE POINT
NINE WHICH WOULD DECRIMINALIZE
SECRET ACTUAL PLAN THANK YOU
NEXT IN LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN SENATORS MY NAME IS
RYAN MAINLY ACADEMIC DIRECTOR
OF MEDITATION AND MINDFULNESS
INSTITUTE FOR HUMANS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EXLINE. LINE TWO
HUNDRED SIX YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JAMES
WEAPON A RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
IMMENSELY I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
WHY TWO HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
YOUR BIKE AT THE- HEY MY NAME'S
TREVOR MOSS BURN AND- I'M IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ONE NINE
ZERO SEVEN MOTIONS HELP. THANK
YOU THANK YOU IT'S TAKING NINE
NAME JOSE A POSITION THANK YOU.
THANKS LINE. WHITE TWO HUNDRED
HERE MIKE AT THE. WHY TWO
HUNDRED YEAR MIKE IS OPEN
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE. HELLO
MY NAME IS CARLOS FOR THE LIME
CARE BECOME ALLIES NATURE AND I
SUPPORT SACRED PLANT SO I
SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE NINE THANK
YOU EXLINE. WHY TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS GEORGE
KRAMER. CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES AND- I MEAN SUPPORTS
VERY STRONG SPPORTER. SB FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU FOR
TREATMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH EXLINE. LINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE YOUR MIKE
IS UP. MY NAME IS DR CENTER
DRIVE BOTTOM AND THIS IS FOR
YOU SEE SANTA CRUZ. AND I A
STRONG SUPPORTER FIVE ONE NINE
THANK YOU. THANKS LINE. LINE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR YOUR MY
KIDS UP IN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR DANCE TEAM AND I READING
A CONSOLIDATED LIST OF SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF NEW APPROACH
ADVOCACY VETERANS EXPLORING
TREATMENT SOLUTIONS. VETERANS
OF WAR THE CITY OF OAKLAND SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTION
PARTNERSHIP MULTI DISCIPLINARY
ASSOCIATION FOR PSYCHEDELIC
STUDIES AND DR BRONNER'S THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO YOUR MIKE
IS OPEN. BRIAN MILLER MARINE
CORPS VETERAN AND FOUNDER OF
OPERATION FEEDBACK EDUCATING
VETERANS ABOUT CONSCIOUSNESS
WITHIN TWENTY ESSEX SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE NINETEEN THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. WHY TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHAEL JUDY I RESIDE IN REDWAY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FIVE NINETEEN THANK
YOU THANKS LINE. WHY TO ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. I AM PICKING OUT
THE RIGHT- UNDER OF WHAT THE
COMMITTEES PSYCHEDELIC
COMMITTEE WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IN SHINING IN
YOUR PLANNING AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE NINE THANK
YOU EXLINE. BLIND TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS CARLA GIPSON AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE
NINE TO ENHANCE OUR STUDY OF
CONSCIOUSNESS THANK YOU SO MUCH
RIGHT NEXT LINE. LIED TWO
HUNDRED SIXTEEN YOUR BY BECAUSE
OF THE- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ERICA FONG EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE MAIN CLINIC AND
A CAPPELLA. OUTBID AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
THE LION TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BOB
HELLO BETTER AND SHE ESCAPED
BUILDERS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TWO NINETEEN THANKFULLY
CRIMINALIZE ANNUALLY NEXT LINE.
ONE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR MIKE AT THE- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JEREMY P.
ON THE U. S. ARMY VETERAN AND A
STRONG SUPPORTER SB FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANKS LINE.
WHITE TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
OPPORTUNITY HERE INCIDENTS MY
NAME IS LOUIS KAHN- YOU TAKE
WITH YOU TO THE SHOOTING IN
PASADENA AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB. FIVE ONE NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.A
LINE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. LINE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN YOUR MIKE
IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON FEATURING
SENATORS FINAL SAVINGS ON THE
SIDE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
FIVE NINETEEN THIRTEEN THANK
YOU EXLINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
WHY TWO HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE. ONE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND BETTER LANES
WHY WILLIAMS I RELIED LOS
ANGELES I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
FIVE ONE NINE THANK YOU DON'T
THINK OF A LANKY FIGURE PLANT
AND WHAT'S NEXT LINE. LINE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HELLO MEDINA
DOLLARS IN THAT FRAME I'M A
TRAUMA THERAPIST AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE NINE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED FORTY
ONE YOUR MIKE AT THE. MY NAME
IS IAN INGRAM- VOLUNTEER WITH A
QUICK JOLT CENTER FOR CULTURAL
SURVIVAL STRONG SUPPORT IN THE
FIVE ONE NINE THANK YOU EXLINE.
WHY TWO HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS RICHIE MAY I AM FOUNDER
OF A OPEN HIGH STATE AND
FOUNDER OF THE FIRST OF SEVEN
CUP ADVISORY BOARD MEMBER OF
THE COMPLY THE NATURE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT- SB. FIVE
NINETEEN BLACK LIVES MATTER
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH NEXT
LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE YOUR MY KIDS UP. HELLO I'M
DR DAN CHRISTIAN I'M A TRAINED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST WOULD BE GRAHAM I
THOUGHT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB FIVE NINETEEN. THANK YOU
MODERATORS WE'VE HEARD TEN OVER
TEN MINUTES OF PUBLIC-
TESTIMONY CAN YOU INDICATE HOW
MANY ADDITIONAL PEOPLE ARE
STILL WAITING TO GIVE TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE-
THIRTEEN MORE PEOPLE WAITING TO
GIVE OKAY THIRTEEN MORE PEOPLE
AND KERR AGAIN- NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION WE DO
KNOW WHAT THE BILL DOES SO- WE
CAN WE CAN QUICKLY GET THROUGH
THOSE- SO- PLEASE- LET'S PLEASE
RESUME THAT TESTIMONY WITNESSES
AND SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. OF SB
FIVE NINETEEN. LINE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GEORGE HEAD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I AM
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB FIVE
NINETEEN I THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
NEXT LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY YOU'RE MY COULD UP. ALL
MY NAME IS MARK MATRAVILLE
FLOOR NAVY SEAL COMBAT VETERAN.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
ONE NINE TO DECRIMINALIZING TWO
POINT ONE THANKS LINE. NOW. ONE
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SIX YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
MATT TO WERE I LIVE IN SAN
DIEGO AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
FIVE ONE NINE THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. WHY TWO HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CINDY
WILLIAMS OKAY THE SENATE STRONG
SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE NINE THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. ONE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER WITH DECRIMINALIZED
INTO SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. WHY TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
SENATORS MY NAME IS ANGEL
POURED I MEAN YOU ARE SIR OF
COURSE REDERI AND IT MENTAL
HEALTH SPECIALISTS AND ALSO
VOLUNTEER WITH THE KERN
CALIFORNIA ALMOND STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ONE NINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SOONER.
THANK YOU THANKS LINE. ALLIED
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
BIKE IS UP AND CHAIR AND
SENATORS MY NAME IS ANNA MARIE
DOT I RESIDE IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
AND SB FIVE ONE NINE. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEVEN MOORE FOR
THE INDIGENOUS PEYOTE
CONSERVATION INITIATIVE AND THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF NATIVE
AMERICAN CHURCHES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETEEN
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU.
THANKS LINE. BLIND TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SIX YOUR MY GET UP WITH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DUSTIN GARNER AND THE SECRETARY
OF THE TENT IN THE UC SANTA
BARBARA I CANNELLA CLUB AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
ONE NINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME LUCY
LAWLESS AND I'M A CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC EDUCATION TEACHER AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE FIVE
ONE NINE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THE LION TWO HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATHERINE
KERNER DEALING WITH CAT I'M ON
THE BOARD OF ELDERS ARE
DECRIMINALIZED NATURE AND I'M
CALLING IN MY STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SB FIVE ONE NINE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
BLINDS THREE HUNDRED HERE MIKE
AT THE- KAREN SENATORS MY NAME
IS CHRIS CANCEL FROM BICYCLE
THE VENTURES OF THE PSYCHEDELIC
VENTURE CAPITALIST AND THE
TRUMP SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ONE
NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. WHITE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY YEAR MY COULD
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JERRY
LYNN INGRAM AND I VIGOROUSLY
SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE NINE THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX MIKE IS UP. ONE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX. I'M NAME IS
ANGELICA LOPEZ AND I'M ON THE
BOARD OF DECLINE NATURE AND
THEN A PERMANENT FULL SUPPORT-
SB FIVE ONE NINE AND- PROVIDING
IT TO ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY I THINK THAT'S THE
THIRTEEN I BELIEVE. IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL PEOPLE- MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
THE PEOPLE TESTIFYING
PARTICULARLY WANT THANK
VETERANS FOR THEIR SERVICE-
LET'S NOW MOVE DOWN TO THE
OPPOSITION SO WE DO HAVE
OPPOSITION. IN THE PUBLIC
GALLERY I. FORD YOU TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE
PROPONENTS GOT. UP TO FOUR
MINUTES- PLEASE- INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND- BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. I THINK IT'S TACK ALLEN
PRESIDENT INTERNATIONAL FAITH
BASED COALITION CONGRESS RACIAL
EQUITY IF I GOT THE CORRECT YES
OKAY WELCOME. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS TACK ALLEN AND I AM
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL FAITH BASED
COALITION OF ALL THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CONGRESS OF RACIAL
EQUALITY. AS A CHILD OF A
FORMER DRUG ADDICT THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE COMMUNITY
THE EXPERIENCE IS PERHAPS THE
LARGEST. IN CONSERVATION
DISPARITIES IN OUR COUNTRY I
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO
ON SB FIVE NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE
NINETEEN ALLOWS ACCESS INTO
SUCH A SHARING OF DRUGS. THAT
ARE NOT YET REGULATED. AND WILL
NOT BE REGULATED FOR QUITE SOME
TIME IF THIS BILL PASSES
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WILL
BE UTILIZED AS GUINEA PIGS IN
EFFORT TO OBTAIN DATA OVER A
PERIOD OF YEARS WELL THE
COMMUNITY SUFFERS AT THE END OF
A BILL THAT HAVE NEGLECTED TO
ADDRESS. THE UNDERLYING CAUSES
OF ADDICTION AND DRUG USE. THE
BILL IS COMPLETELY AFTER THE
TREATMENT OPTIONS FOR ADDICTS
PREVENTION EDUCATION PRODUCTION
REACHING USERS AS WELL AS
HEALTH AND SOCIAL RESOURCES FOR
THE COMMUNITY TO EXPERIENCE THE
MOST SHAUNA FROM THIS BILL.
THAT IS LOW INCOME. COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. ELL
THE INTO OF THE BILL GREAT IT
FALLS FLAT AS A SLOT. ONE HARM
AN ATTEMPT TO REMEDY. FOR
SEVERAL OTHER HARMS THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED. FIFTY DOLLARS FOR
THE SOCIAL SHARING OF
SUBSTANCES THAT CAN BE
ESPECIALLY HARMFUL TO BILLS.
FOR ADDICTION. SUGGESTION WAS
IN ITSELF. AS A GATEWAY TO MORE
ADULT INDUCTION RACING USERS.
WHY IS IT IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER
BECAUSE BOTH IN THE COMMUNITIES
AND IN POVERTY BOTH OF LOWER
EDUCATION SUBSETS ARE THOSE
MORE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE. TO
BE AS AN ADDICTION BY ALLOWING
THE PERPETUATION OF DRUG USE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES WE HINDER THE
NEXT GENERATION COMING UP FROM
BEING ABLE TO OVERCOME THE
OBSTACLES THEY ARE EXPERIENCING
AT THIS PRESENT MOMENT. TO
REJECT THE UNDERLYING ISSUE
EVERY COUPLE OF REGARDLESS OF
THE CITIES AND PROVIDE
TREATMENT OPTIONS TO
COMMUNITIES IN NEED THIS BILL
SERVES AS AN IRRESPONSIBLE AND
HASTY MANDATE THAT WILL CREATE
A GREAT DEAL ABOUT QUESTIONS
PLEASE ALREADY SUFFERING. I
URGE A NO VOTE. SB FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TESTIMONY BALLOTS ON TO NO IT
AND- TO SB FIVE NINETEEN WILL
BEGIN WITH THE PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE OTHER WITNESSES UP IN
PUBLIC GALLERY THIS WITH THE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SAYING NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR. PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE NINETEEN AGAIN THIS IS FOR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
IF THAN EURO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE
DO HAVE A FEW COMMENTS COMING
FOR ONE MOMENT PLEASEWHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH LINE NUMBERS
THANK YOU. IN A LINE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO YOUR MY KIDS
UP. DEGREE BURKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE YOUR MIKE IS UP.
TURNIER DOLLARS PER CAPITA
RESEARCH INSTITUTE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
YOUR MIKE ITSELF BUT. HI MY
NAME IS DON DAVIS I AM A MEMBER
OF THE SHAMANIC TRIED TO PHD
CANDIDATE AND SCHOLAR WITH OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS OF. RESEARCH
CENTENE THE NEW I NEED OF
AMERICAN CHURCH. THE
GOVERNMENT'S GOVERNMENT
CONSULTATION HAS NOT OCCURRED.
WHICH WE'RE JUST TAKING NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY SO I
PRESUME YOU'RE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE NINETEEN.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. YES THIS IS JOHN
LEVEL WITH THE- CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE OF
THE UNREGULATED SOCIAL SHARING
PROVISION WAS JUST A REAL NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION PLEASE
SELF THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPOSITION. NEXT LINE PLEASE.
ISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU LET'S NOW MOVE TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
YES CENTER MELENDEZ. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN- SO FIRST I WANT TO
START OFF BY THANKING FOR THE
ON THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING AN
INTEREST IN FINDING ALTERNATIVE-
METHODS TO TREAT SOME OF THESE
AILMENTS THAT WE HAVE YET TO BE
ABLE TO CONQUER- BUT I. I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT SOME OF
THE DRUGS THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
TO DECRIMINALIZE SPECIFICALLY-
THE DRUG KADAM MEANS- CAN MEAN
IS ONE OF THE THREE MAJOR.
DRUGS USED AS A DATE RAPE DRUG.
AND I HAVE GREAT CONCERN THAT
THIS BILL WOULD LEGALIZE THE
POSSESSION OF A DATE RAPE DRUG
JUST IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN-
OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE SENATOR
GALGIANI HAD A BILL. PRESENTED
PASSED AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR THAT WOULD- MAKE IT A
CRIME TO HAVE THAT DRUG FOR
OBVIOUS REASONS. AND SAID THIS
BILL SEEMS TO WORK IN
CONTRADICTION TO THAT EFFORT- I
UNDERSTAND THAT CAN MEAN. THE
IN SOME FORMS IS BEING USED ON
TO TREAT DEPRESSION- THAT YOU
KNOW IS NOT ABLE TO BE TREATED
BY OTHER MEANS. THE HERE
THERE'S SOME IT'S JUST STUBBORN
AND THE PERSON QUITE CAN'T GET
BEYOND IT SO THERE'S- SOME
CLINICAL TRIALS AND TESTING
TAKING PLACE IN SEEING IF CAN I
MEAN CAN BE USEFUL IN TREATING
SEVERE DEPRESSION DEPRESSION
THAT HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO- HAVE
BEEN TREATED BY OTHER DRUGS. IN
AN PTSD SORRY RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE MAY BE- SOME CLINICAL
BENEFITS TO USING THIS DRUG FOR
DEPRESSION. HOWEVER I'M- WHEN
CAN I MEAN IS USED TO TREAT
DEPRESSION OR PTSD IT IS USED
IN A CLINICAL SETTING SO
THERE'S TWO FORMS- THERE'S AN
INTRAVENOUS FORM AND THEN
THERE'S A NASAL SPRAY BOTH OF
WHICH HAVE TO BE USED IN A
MEDICAL SETTING UNDER MEDICAL
SUPERVISION- IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT A DOCTOR PRESCRIBES AND
HANDS OVER TO A PATIENT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT MUST BE DONE IN
A MEDICAL SETTING. SO IT'S
UNCLEAR TO ME HOW SOMEONE
HAVING A- SMALL AMOUNT OF THIS
TYPE OF A DRUG. ON THEIR PERSON
COULD BE IT COULD POSSIBLY BE
USED FOR TREATING DEPRESSION OR
PTSD BECAUSE THAT'S CURRENTLY
NOT HOW IT'S BEING ADMINISTERED
FOR THE TREATMENT OF THESE
TYPES OF AILMENTS SO I WONDER
IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO THAT
BEFORE I MOVE ON TO MY OTHER
QUESTIONS. EARLIER IF YOU WISH
TO ANSWER YES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU OUT CENTER
MELENDEZ FOR- FOR THE QUESTION-
ON THE BILL OF COURSE DOES NOT
IN ANY WAY LEGALIZE OR
DECRIMINALIZE. DATE RAPE OR
TRUCKING ANYONE OUT. TO RATE
FROM- THAT WILL REMAIN- AN
EXCEPTIONALLY SERIOUS. CRIME AS
IT SHOULD BE- I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO. ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
THE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT IN A
QUORUM COURT DATE RAPE DRUGS
FIRST OF ALL. THE MOST COMMON
DATE RAPE DRUG IS A DRUG CALLED
ALCOHOL. AND THEN THERE'S GHB
WHICH IS NOT PART OF THIS BILL
AND THEN THERE ON IS- REFORM
CALLED FOR RUPEES. RIGHT SO ON
AND SO THERE ARE VARIOUS
SUBSTANCES THAT CAN BE USED IN
A REALLY. YOU KNOW AT THE END
OF SOMEONE'S ASSAULTING SOMEONE
ELSE. SLIPPING SOMEONE IN THEIR
DRINK OR JUST GETTING THEM VERY
INTOXICATED ON ALCOHOL AND THEN
DO SOMETHING HORRIBLE- AND
THEY- SHOULD BE PROSECUTED AND
THE STILL DESIGN ANYWAY. STOP
THAT FROM HAPPENING- AND BUT
JUST AGAIN GOING BACK TO BASICS
WITH. THIS BILL IS ABOUT. IS
SHOULD SOMEONE BE PROSECUTED IN
A ROW. FOR POSSESSING THE DRUG.
A AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT DRUG
DECRIMINALIZATION IS ABOUT
SHOULD BE ARRESTING AND
PROSECUTION FOR POSSESSING THE
DRUG ON CADMIUM DOES HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT. THERAPEUTIC
BENEFITS AND IT IS USED AND NOT
HUESO ANY DRUG CAN BE MISUSED
THERE ARE DRUGS THAT ARE LEGAL
TODAY RIGHT NOW. SEE PEOPLE'S
LIVES BUT CAN ALSO BE MISUSED-
AND SO THAT THAT'S REALLY AN
ISSUE THAT IS NOT ANYWHERE
UNIQUE- TO COMING- THANK YOU SO
MISTER CHAIR- YES. JUST MOVING
ON I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
THAT THE USE OF CAN MEAN- THERE
TO USES WELL TO THE WILL SPEAK
ABOUT TODAY ONE IS IN. A
CLINICAL SETTING MORE IT IS
ADMINISTERED BY MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND THE PATIENT
IS OBSERVED IN ITS EITHER
INTRAVENOUSLY GIVEN OR IT IS
THROUGH A NASAL SPRAY BUT AGAIN
MUST BE IN A MEDICAL SETTING IT
IS NOT HANDED OUT TO A PATIENT-
AND IT IS NOT IT'S- IT HASN'T
BEEN PROVEN YET TO BE
COMPLETELY EFFECTIVE IN
TREATING THESE- ELEMENTS
THEY'RE THEY'RE WORKING ON
THAT- THERE IS. I HAVE A
ARTICLE HERE FROM THE HARVARD
MEDICAL SCHOOL THAT SAYS
FURTHER RESEARCH COMPARING
EFFECTIVENESS AND SIDE EFFECTS
IS NEEDED- ADDITIONALLY. LAKE
OPIOIDS CAN MEAN HAS ADDICTIVE
PROPERTIES IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND THIS WHEN WEIGHING
RISKS AND BENEFITS IF YOU HAVE
A HISTORY OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE
WHICH IS VERY COMMON AT LEAST
WITH- WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
VETERANS WITH PTSD. ISTORY OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SUCH AS ALCOHOL
OR DRUGS. THEN CAME TO ME MAY
NOT BE A GOOD OPTION FOR YOU
WITH THE NASAL SPRAY- THIS IS
GIVEN. SPACE FIVE MINUTES APART
UNDER DOCTOR SUPERVISION YOU
REMAIN IN THE CLINIC UNDER DR
OBSERVATION UNTIL POTENTIAL
SIDE EFFECTS HAVE PASSED. IN
ADDITIONALLY- IT X. THERE ARE
SOME EXPERTS WHO HAVE A
QUESTION THE EFFICACY AND
SAFETY OF THIS DRUG IN PART
BECAUSE IN CLINICAL TRIALS
THREE STUDY PARTICIPANTS
COMMITTED SUICIDE AFTER THEIR
LAST AND DOES SO AGAIN- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS SHOWS SOME
PROMISE CERTAINLY BUT IT IS
ALSO USED AS A DATE RAPE DRUG
IN WHICH- AND WE- IT IS
ILLEGAL. TO HAVE THE DRUG IN
YOUR POSSESSION FOR THAT EFFORT
AND IF YOU MAKE IT LEGAL. TO
POSSESS THIS. THEN YOU WERE
OPENING UP THE DOOR. IT IS. TO
ESSENTIALLY EIGHT YOU KNOW A
LICENSE TO SIN N USING THIS
DRUG FOR NEFARIOUS PURPOSES I
MEAN THAT'S JUST A REALITY IF
YOU SAY IT'S OKAY THAT YOU CAN
HAVE THIS DRUG IN YOUR POCKET.
YOU MAY CATCH SOME OF THE
PEOPLE WHO USE IT. TO SEXUALLY
ASSAULT SOMEONE BUT THERE ARE
GOING TO BE AN AWFUL LOT OF
OTHERS THAT YOU DON'T CATCH.
IT'S DIFFICULT SO WHILE I
RECOGNIZE. THAT THERE ARE SOME
THERAPEUTICS THAT CAN BE USED
OUT THERE TO TREAT SOME OF
THESE- DIFFERENT ISSUES. ARE I
DON'T KNOW THAT THE- CHANGING A
LAW THAT WE MADE IN. TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN- IS. IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE PUBLIC
HELP OR CERTAINLY FROM FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OF WOMEN IN THEIR
SAFETY AT THIS POINT SO-
UNFORTUNATELY I WILL BE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL TODAY
THANK YOU- MAY. D. JEWISH TO
LOG DOT DR GRANT WERE WITNESSES
IS ACTION EXPERT ON KATAMON
THERAPY AND- IF THERE'S A
DESIRE TO HEAR FROM ONE OF OUR
TOPICS WHO ARE TO MOVE ALL AGES
WHATEVER THAT QUESTIONS CENTER
MELENDEZ ARE OKAY SO THAT BUT
PERHAPS OF SOMEONE ELSE WHICH
IS TO POSE THAT QUESTION WE CAN
ASK YOUR EXPERT TO ANSWER THAT
WITH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES SIR LEYVA. OPPOSITE
QUESTION TO THE DOCTOR HOW DOES
THE CAT MING THERAPY WORK
BECAUSE I KNOW I HAVE HEARD.
THAT IT'S FROM IT IS VERY MUCH
HELP SOME PEOPLE TO RECOVER
FROM MENTAL ILLNESS OR LIVE
WITH THEIR MENTAL ILLNESS SO I
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM THE
DOCTOR. OKAY SO IF WE CAN BRING
DR GRANT ON THE LINE TO ADDRESS
US OR LEAVE US A QUESTION ABOUT
USES OF COMMUNITY THERAPEUTIC.
SENSE AND PERHAPS- IF YOU DON'T
MIND WILL FOCUS IT ON THE
TRAIN- THAT FORMS A WHICH IT
WOULD BE ON A PERSON SO NOT I.
V. WHICH I'VE EXPECTS ONE
TURNAROUND IV BAGS SO TINY BUT.
OTHER USES. OF CAN I MEAN. OCT
GRANT. KIDDING IT IT IS
EFFECTIVE FOR TREATMENT OF
DEPRESSION AND THAT'S-
GENERALLY SAY IT'S USED IN A
VARIETY OF FORMATS- SOME OF
THEM ARE INTRAVENOUS OR
INTRAMUSCULAR INJECTION BUT IN
ADDITION TO MEAN IS THE LIVER
BY INTRA NASAL SPRAY OR BY. LAW
LOS. AND ALL OF THOSE FORMATS
THERE ARE AT LEAST ONE
PUBLISHED STUDY SHOWING. VERY
HIGH RESPONSE RATES IN
DEPRESSION WHICH WE HOPE
COMPRESSION INSIDE ALITY OF.
MORE THAN 6270% OF PEOPLE BY
THE END OF THE FIRST DAY OF
TREATMENT SO IT'S A REMARKABLY
EFFECTIVE MEDICINE FOR THE
TREATMENT OF DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDAL CRISIS- THE NASAL FORM
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE FOOD
AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION SO- AT
THIS POINT IT'S NO LONGER
INVESTIGATION WHAT IT'S
REGARDED BY THE FDA AND THE
STATE'S RECRUITMENT. AFTER.
DEPRESSION SUICIDALITY- THERE
ARE STUDIES ON GOING ABOUT.
HOME NEWS INTRANASAL SPRAY AS
WELL AS THE ASSEMBLY CORPORATE
LOZENGES IT MIGHT BE. THE
PERSON- I AGREE WITH DR WIENER
THAT. HELLO THIS MEDICINE- HI
IS NOT THE MOST COMMON- DRUG
USE ON. HOW CALL BY FAR IS THAT
CORRECT BEIJING PUTS MOST
COMMONLY USE OF COURSE SO-
INCOME. YOUR TICKET YOU SEEN
THAT- PROHIBITING THE CARRYING
OF THESE MEDICINES IT'S NOT
PERMANENT SO WE HAVE. SEPARATE
STRATEGIES FOR. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MAYBE I'LL JUST ASK
ONE QUICK FOLLOW UP QUESTION
SINCE WE HAVE THE GOOD DR GRANT
ON THE LINE- AS A FELLOW
PHYSICIAN I ALSO UNDERSTAND-
THAT KIND OF MEAN ORALLY HAS
BEEN USED FOR CHRONIC PAIN
AGAIN PERHAPS THE MOST COMMON
FORM BUT- DAVID STATE I HAVE
RUN ACROSS- RESEARCH LURCH
SHOWN SOME EFFICACY IN MANAGING
CHRONIC PAIN AS WELL AND ORAL
FORM IS ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH
THAT LITERATURE. THAT IS
CORRECT I MEAN IN ORAL FORM IS.
JUST HELPFUL OF PAIN MANAGEMENT
AND IS COMMONLY USED IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THIS. THANK YOU
I'M GLAD TO KNOW THE YOU TO
HAVE SEEN SIMILAR SURE OF THE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
SEVERAL MONTHS SORRY I'M
KEEPING AN EYE ON THE HANDS UP
THEIR SETTLEMENT. IT'S YOUR
CHAIR- I WANT TO START OFF BY-
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD IT'S A BILL AT THE
SCENE I HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO
DISCUSS AND THEY CERTAINLY
SPENT A BIT OF TIME. LOOKING
INTO THIS IN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE I WOULD FALL.
WHAT IT WHAT I REALLY LIKE
ABOUT THIS BILL IT IS THE FACT
THAT IT CREATES A TASK FORCE AN
EXPERT WORKING GROUP ANY THINK
ALIGNS WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WITH THE FDA
ALSO LOOKING INTO THIS- I I'D
LOVE THE IDEA THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S ALSO LOOKING- AT
BRINGING TOGETHER- SOAPS THAT
CAN HELP US THINK THROUGH THE
ISSUES. YOU KNOW HOWEVER I DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS- WHICH I'VE
SHARED WITH THE AUTHOR- ALTICE
IN THOSE HAVE TO DO ALSO WITH
THE LEGALIZATION. MDMA WHICH AT
TIMES CAN BE CUT WITH THINGS
LIKE MATH- AND I THINK THAT-
YOU KNOW I TRIED TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE I WAS GONNA FALL WITH
THIS- IN IN THE END. YOU KNOW I
DON'T KNOW THAT I CAN BE THERE.
YOU KNOW TODAY BUT I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS A BILL
THAT REQUIRES A LOT OF US TO
THINK ABOUT WHATEVER LAND. I
DON'T DOUBT. THAT THERE.
ANYTHING THE EVIDENCE SHOWS
THAT THERE IS VALUE IN
PSYCHEDELICS- FOR THOSE. YOU
KNOW THAT IT. THAT NEEDED OR
THEY CAN FIND IT HELPFUL I
THINK THAT WHERE MY DISCOMFORT
LIES. IS REALLY IN IN IN THIS
KIND OF MULTI PROCESS OF HAVING
EXPERT GROUPS CONVENE- BUT
ALMOST ACTEON ON THIS BEFORE
THE EXPERT GROUPS HELP US THINK
THROUGH SOME OF THESE ISSUES
THE EXPERT GROUP GROUP BEING
THE TASK FORCE BUT ALSO KNOWING
THAT THE FDA- AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IS LOOKING AT THIS SO.
THAT YOU KNOW I WANT TO BE SURE
THAT EXPLAIN WHY I WILL BE
THERE ON THIS BILL BUT ALSO. DO
YOU REALLY THINK THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
THAT'S BEEN PUT INTO THIS AND
DESPITE MY COMFORT LEVEL WITH
THIS. BILL TODAY I DO
UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE ASKING
OURSELVES THESE QUESTIONS THAT
WHILE WE'RE MOVING FORWARD. ON
SOME OF THESE ISSUES SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER LIMóN-
THE CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AND I'D ALSO LIKE
THE AUTHOR FOR GETTING TO US
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD-
HAVING SPENT TIME WORKING IN
AROUND ADDICTION. I CAN SAY
THAT THE DRUG THAT HAS HAD THEM
THE WORST IMPACT HEALTH FAMILY
LEGAL. IS A VERY LEGAL DRUG
ALCOHOL. AND THAT REMAINS LEGAL
AND- AND A MAIN PART OF OUR
ECONOMY AS WELL AS OUR SOCIETY.
SO I WOULD JUST SAY AS- WHEN
THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE I ILL
MOVE THIS BILL- AND BECAUSE THE
QUESTION BEFORE US RIGHT NOW
REALLY IS AGAIN IF WE IF WE
LIKE OR DON'T LIKE OR- OR
SOMETHING COULD BE USED IT IS
AN ABUSE OF WAY WE KNOW ANY
DRUG HER. OR A KNIFE OR A GUN
OR ANYTHING IT CAN BE USED- TO
HURT OTHERS THAT IS NOT THE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL THIS
BILL SIMPLY SAYS. FOR THIS
GROUP OF SUBSTANCES SHOULD WE
BE ARRESTING AND- CRIMINALIZING
AND PUTTING PEOPLE IN JAIL. FOR
POSITION THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
SAYING. AND SO IT WAS STRICTLY
MOVE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ORDER AND OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY YEAH CENTER
MELENDEZ YES I'M SORRY MR
CHAIRMAN I JUST HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE- IT I AM. SEEING HERE
THAT IT'S IT SAYS- THE BILL
COMMISSION TO WORKING GROUP
REPORT AND RECOMMENDATIONS. ON
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
IMPLICATIONS OF DECRIMINALIZING
THESE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES AND
IDENTIFICATION OF REGULATED USE
MODELS FROM OTHER JURISDICTIONS
BY THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
AND I AM- I GUESS WONDERING WHY
THAT WOULD GO INTO EFFECT TWO
YEARS AFTER. THIS LAW WOULD GO
INTO EFFECT WHY WOULD WHY WOULD
WE COMMISSION A STUDY ON DOING
THE VERY THING THAT. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO DO IT. SENATE WIENER I
THANK YOU MR SO THE PURPOSE OF
THE WORKING GROUP IS NOT TO
GIVE AN OPINION ABOUT WHETHER
WE SHOULD DECRIMINALIZE THE
PURPOSE OF THE WORKING GROUP'S
THE SECOND ONCE WE HAVE
STOPPED. ARRESTING AND
PROSECUTING FOR PEOPLE FOR
POSSESSING THE SUBSTANCES. WHAT
CAN WE THINK ABOUT IN THE
FUTURE IN TERMS OF POTENTIAL.
REGULATION YOU RECALL THAT WITH
FOR EXAMPLE CANNABIS. WE DID IT
IN TWO STEPS FIRST THE VOTERS
STEPPED IN AND SAID THEY WERE.
GOING TO DECRIMINALIZE-
MEDICINAL CANNABIS- HONESTLY
THAT WAS EFFECTIVELY
DECRIMINALIZATION IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND THEN TWENTY
YEARS LATER- THE VOTERS PASSED
ON THE ADULT USE MORE
REGULATORY- OUR SYSTEM IS A TWO
SEPARATE THINGS. AND SO THE
PURPOSE OF TASK FORCES THAT
OKAY NOW WE'VE DECRIMINALIZED.
STOPPED ARRESTING PEOPLE- WHY
DO WE DO IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE
THAT IS FRANKLY EVEN THAT'S
MORE COMPLICATED- IN TERMS OF
POTENTIAL REGULATION- THERE ARE
ACTIVE THE DATES RIGHT NOW
ABOUT COMMERCIALIZATION. AS
THERE ARE WITH FRANKLY WITH
WITH CANNABIS- AND SO THAT
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE- OF
THE OF THE TASK FORCE. AND I HI
I WAS THAT WE DON'T NEED A TASK
FORCE TO TELL US THAT ARRESTING
JAILING AND CRIMINALIZING
PEOPLE FOR DRUG POSSESSION WE
DON'T NEED A TEST FIRST TELL US
ABOUT THIS AND MARK. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I DON'T
SEE ANY MICROPHONES UP NO HE
ENDS UP- SO CENTER WIENER- THE
ESTIMATE YOU KNOW I'M NOT NOT
THE MOST ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORTER
OF YOUR BILL- SOMEONE WHO IS
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY CONCERNED- I
THINK- ABOUT- ABOUT WHAT IMPACT
THESE SUBSTANCES CAN HAVE HELP
AT THE SAME TIME AS YOU POINTED
OUT- FIRST OF ALL THEY D. AT
YOUR DATE- CRIMINALIZING IT
DEFINITELY HAS A NEGATIVE
IMPACT. AND IT'S INTERESTING
THAT WE BROUGHT UP ALCOHOL
SEVERAL TIMES BECAUSE IN THIS
COUNTRY WE DID TRY
CRIMINALIZING ALCOHOL. AND WITH
THIS WE FIGURED OUT HOW QUICKLY
HOW BADLY THAT TURNE OUT IN
FACT IN WEEK I'M CRIMINALIZED
ALCOHOLS- SO WE ACTUALLY TRIED
THAT EXPERIMENT HERE- WE'RE
DOING IT AGAIN WE'VE DONE IT
AGAIN WITH OTHER SUBSTANCES
INCLUDING PSYCHEDELICS- BUT
ALSO NOTING THAT- WE TALK ABOUT
PSYCHEDELICS AT LEAST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE- YOU KNOW THERE'D.
THEY'RE NOT ADDICTIVE PER SE-
SO I THINK I HAVE A TRY HAVE A
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT ATTITUDE
TOWARD SOME OTHER SUBSTANCES
THAT WOULD- BE MORE ADDICTIVE
WHAT'S HARD FOR SOMEONE TO. TO
STOP USAGE- THE AS YOU POINTED
OUT THEY DO HAVE THERAPEUTIC
BENEFITS. MANY OF THEM- WELL
GENERALLY I WOULD SAY THOSE
SHOULD BE HANDLED UNDER
PRESCRIPTION I'D ALSO MAKE NOTE
THAT I AGREE WITH YOU THAT JUST
BECAUSE SOMEONE POSSESSING IT.
SHOULDN'T BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOMEONE TO GET NOW FIND
THEMSELVES ENGAGE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND WITH THAT YOU
KNOWI DO THINK YOU MAKES US
SOME VERY COMPELLING ARGUMENTS
IN TERMS OF THE LEVEL OF HARM
TO OR CREATING BY CRIMINALIZING
THE SUBSTANCES. A TIED IT IN WE
DO NEED TO PROVISION- AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION'S
TESTIMONY THAT IT'S NOT. THAT
YOU KNOW WE- THAT WE DO NEED
RIGHT SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE WHO
MAY HAVE. NEGATIVE EXPERIENCES
OR HAVE- YOU KNOW AND ACCESS
TO. THE SITE AT THE SUBSTANCES
THAT THAT THAN FORGING TURNED
OUT BADLY- YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S OF ACCESS TO SUBSTANCE
USE TREATMENT AND SO FORTH. BUT
I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO AT
LEAST- THIS PARTICULAR. SET OF-
SUBSTANCES- GIVEN BOTH THEIR
POTENTIAL THERAPEUTIC BENEFIT
AS WELL AS- I THINK THE WELL
THERE'S CERTAINLY SOME RISK OF
HARM THAT- I THINK THAT THAT-
BUT- IT'S SOMETHING THAT- THE
HARM FROM THE GLOBALIZATION
THINK IT'S MUCH WORSE. SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I APPRECIATE THAT.
DISCUSSION I'M SURE YOU HAVE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
BILL AS A NEWS FORD. I
APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING THIS
BEFORE US AND ALLOWING US TO
HAVE THIS DEBATE. AND I THINK
IT'S ONE THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE AND- CERTAINLY TO
POLICY WE CERTAINLY NEED TO
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER. SO THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MR
AND I REALLY APPRECIATETHOSE
THOUGHTFUL REMARKS- AND YOU
KNOW. WE KNOW THAT. WITH ANY
SUBSTANCE LEGAL ILLEGAL ANY
SUBSTANCE. CAN BE. MISUSED HI-
ANY SUBSTANCE YOU CAN HAVE A
PERSON CAN HAVE A- HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIP. WITH ANY
SUBSTANCE LEGAL OR ILLEGAL-
AND- AND THAT'S WHY MISTER YOU
AND I AND WE ALL MANY OF US IN
YOUR WORK CLOSELY TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THE FOR PEOPLE WHO DO
DEVELOP. HARMFUL OR UNHEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS WITH ANY
SUBSTANCE WHETHER IT'S ALCOHOL
OR MATH OR ANY SUBSTANCE THAT
WE HAVE IT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT TO
ADDICTION TREATMENT AND THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN FANTASTIC
AND MOVING FORWARD. BILLS AND-
YOU KNOW SENT A CENTER EGGMAN
AND I ARE WORKING TOGETHER AND-
ON A LEADING OR MENTAL HEALTH
CAUCUS AND SO- WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO MAKE SURE AND WE NEED
TO DO MORE. TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
ARE STRUGGLING WHETHER WITH THE
WITH ADDICTION OR OR EVEN IF A
DRUG IS NOT ADDICTIVE JUST WITH
AN UNHEALTHY RELATIONSHIP
WITHOUT DRUGS. BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT PSYCHEDELIC SUBSTANCES.
CAN ALSO SAVE LIVES AND WE'VE
HEARD A AND FOR THE VETERAN
THAT WE HEARD FROM WE COULD
HAVE YOU KNOW IF WE ALL THE
TIME IN THE WORLD. PUT A
HUNDRED VETERANS UP THERE. OR
WE COULD TALK TO A FORMER
COLLEAGUE OF MINE. BACK IN THE
OLD WAY BACK IN THE DAY WHEN I
WAS A LAWYER IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE- HE AND HIS WIFE THEIR
SON IS A TEENAGER BECAME BADLY
ADDICTED TO HEROIN AND THERE'S
A LETTER IN THE RECORD FROM
HIM. AND THEY TRIED EVERYTHING
UNDER THE SUN. TO GET HIM OFF
OF HER OWN EVERYTHING FAILED IN
THEIR RESOURCES AND EVERYTHING
FELT. UNTIL THEY SENT HIM TO
NOT BROUGH LIKE OUR VETERAN HAD
TO GO TO MEXICO FOR IDLE GAME
TREATMENT AND HE HAS NOT USED
HER WHEN SENSE WE SHOULD NOT BE
FORCING PEOPLE. UNDERGROUND OR
TO TRAVEL TO ANOTHER COUNTRY TO
GET TREATMENT TO SAVE THEIR
LIVES. WE SHOULD BE TAKING
THOSE STEPS AND ALLOWING PEOPLE
ACCESS HERE THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT. J. REALLY THOUGHT
DISCUSS TODAY COLLEAGUES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR WIENER AT
THE IT'S THIS BILL'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER EGGMAN- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN H CAN I AM A LINDA'S NO
MELINDA'S NO EGGMAN. AYE EGGMAN
AYE AND SALAS HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HER TADO. LEYVA HI LEYVA
AYE LEE MON. ROTH ROTH OF ROTH
AYE RUBIO. WIENER FIVE WIENER
HI. SIX ONE. IS ONE. OF THOSE
CURRENTLY SIX ONE WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT IS OKAY GOOD IT'S AN
EXCITING TIME NUMBER SEVEN SP
FIVE FIVE EIGHT BY CENTER
CAPITAL WELCOME. HE'S BEEN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE TO
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS NUMBER ONE
TO DECIMATE CAL OVER YES IS THE
LEAD AGENCY OF THE FARMER
DISASTER RELIEF TASK FORCE.
NUMBER TWO TO PROVIDE MORE TIME
FOR THE TASK FORCE REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB
FIVE FIVE EIGHT A SIMPLE BUT
IMPORTANT BILL. THE BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH THE FORMER DISASTER
RELIEF PLANNING TASK FORCE TO
EXAMINE THE NEEDS OF
FARMWORKERS THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES FOR IMMEDIATE
INTERMEDIATE AND LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE
ACCESS. TO HEALTH CARE SAFETY
NET SERVICES AND OTHER SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC RELIEF DESERT
DURING DISASTERS AND PANDEMICS.
CREATING THIS TASK FORCE IS
CRITICAL FOR A STATE TO BE IN
THE RIGHT POSITION TO ASSIST
FARMWORKERS DURING THE MOST
CRITICAL TIME OF NEED. DURING
TIMES OF A DISASTER.
FARMWORKERS ARE AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE WORKERS IN OUR STATE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE AS WE
EXPERIENCE CLIMATE. RELATED
EMERGENCY EVENTS SUCH AS
WILDFIRES AND DROUGHTS. AS YOU
KNOW THE PANDEMIC HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY. AFFECTED
FARMWORKERS HELP. THE ANALYSIS
PROVIDES A GOOD SUMMARY OF THE
RECENT UC BERKELEY WHITE PAPER
ON THE IMPACT OF COVERED
NINETEEN ON FARMWORKERS. FORMER
COMMUNITIES FEEL LEFT BEHIND
AND RIGHTLY SO THE COMMUNITIES
LIKE MANY RESOURCES WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED INCLUDING ACCESS TO
CLEAN WATER AFFORDABLE HOUSING
HEALTH CARE AND FOOD. IN THE
PAST FEW MONTHS I HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN MANY FOOD P. P.
E. N. NOW VACCINE DISTRIBUTIONS
THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT AND I'VE
SEEN THE GREAT NEED TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THESE HARD
WORKING FAMILIES. AND TO ENSURE
SUCH ASSISTANCE IS PROVIDED IN
A COORDINATED EFFICIENT AND
NIMBLE APPROACH. THE
UNPRECEDENTED PANDEMIC
NECESSITATED AN IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE TO THE EVER CHANGING
SITUATION WE SAW MANY GAPS. FOR
EXAMPLE LACK OF CULTURALLY
RELEVANT INFORMATION ON THE
PANDEMIC LACK OF ACCESS TO KOBE
TESTING AND P. P. E. LACK OF
ACCESS TO FOOD DISTRIBUTION AND
OTHER GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. AND FINALLY. BLACK OF
ACCESS TO VACCINES. THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT WE RELY ON OUR ON
THE COUNTIES TO BE OUR- TO WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY RESOURCES.
AND THE FACT THAT EVERY COUNTY
ATTACK THIS ISSUE IT IN A
TOTALLY DIFFERENT WAY MADE IT
VERY DIFFICULT. TO FIRST OF ALL
UNDERSTAND WHAT KIND OF
COORDINATION OR LACK OF
COORDINATION WAS GOING ON BUT
ALSO WHAT KIND OF SERVICES WERE
AVAILABLE AND HOW TO BE ABLE TO
DISTRIBUTE THAT INFORMATION TO
THE FARMWORKERS COMMUNITY SO
THAT THEY KNEW HOW TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. THEY KNEW WERE TO
ACCESS RESOURCES AND THEY KNEW-
WHO IS IN CHARGE AND WHO WAS
WHO WAS LOOKING OUT FOR THEM.
WE SAW THE NEED FOR BETTER
COORDINATION WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORK
WITH FARMWORKERS EVERYDAY AS
WELL. GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS OFTEN
TIMES DID NOT INCLUDE THEIR
INPUT. WHAT I PROPOSE WITH THIS
BILL IS A CALIFORNIA DO BETTER
IN THE FUTURE. THE TASK FOCE
WILL HELP OUR STATE RESPONDED
WITH AN EQUITY LENS AT THE
FOREFRONT. THANK YOU AND I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS JOEL
DERRINGER. OF DERRINGER AND
ASSOCIATE AND STRONG ADVOCATE
FOR FARMWORKER HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THANK YOU SENATOR AVAIL
MODERATOR PRE PLEASE BRING- THE
PHONE LINES OUTSIDE TOLD DURING
THE- FROM DURRINGTON SOCIUS TO
TESTIFY BY TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF S. C. FIVE FIVE EIGHT. AND
YOU HAVE- TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
THE ABILITY TO COMMENT ON THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF THIS CRLA
FOUNDATION MY NAME IS DAHLE
DERRINGER COUPLE CHRIS
CHEVROLET FOUNDATION FOR THE
ENTIRE TIME DURING CULTIVATED
AND TRYING TO GET RELIEF FOR
FARMWORKERS COMMUNITIES I ALSO
FACILITATED SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
FARMWORKERS. CONSORTIUM FROM
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN WORKING ON ANOTHER
DISASTER. AT CENTER CUT BY SAID
THIS IS THE DEAL CUTS A
FARMWORKERS. PLANNING TASK
FORCE TO LEARN FROM PAST
DISASTERS ADDRESS PRESIDENT OF
DISASTERS AND PREPARE FOR
FUTURE DISASTERS HE CAN BE
CLIMATE RELATED WHETHER THEY
ARE CREDIBLE FLOODING HE WILD
HIGHER FREEZES. ARE THEY BEAT
PENN D'AMICO. OR CAN EVEN BE
ECONOMIC RELATED AS WITH THE
GREAT RECESSION- IN OUR WORK
WITH FARM WORKER COMMUNITIES
WE'VE LEARNED SEVERAL THINGS
ONE IS THAT SENATOR. STATED
THAT THERE IS A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHAT CO MADE THEIR
FAR MORE LIKELY TO CONTRACT.
PROBATED AND SUFFER
CONSEQUENCES YET THEY LAGGED
AND ACCESS TO TESTING
VACCINATION AND MANY OTHER WILL
BE BENEFITS FARMWORKERS WERE
CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL FROM
BEGINNING. BUT FELT INVISIBLE.
IT'S BEEN A DISK IN THOSE
RELIEF BETWEEN STATE AGENCIES
AND SYMBIOZ COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- THAT ARE WELL
MEANING STATE TRIGGERING
RESPONSES BY MULTIPLE AGENCIES
BUT OFTEN WITHOUT COORDINATION
AMONG THE AGENCIES AND
POTENTIALLY LOOK LOCAL
AGENCIES. AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ON THE GROUND.
WE'VE HAD IT'S A SENATOR
STATED- DISPARATE RESPONSES BY
COUNTIES. FOR INSTANCE DURING
THE DROUGHT DISEMBARKING VALLEY
COUNTY THE NUMBER OF THEM WOULD
NOT APPLY FOR DRIVING. IT HAS
BEEN ON BEHALF OF FORMER KING
ENTITIES AND SINCE THE STATE
THE COUNTER. OUR MAJOR PARTNERS
THAT SERVICE A PROBLEM THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS.
GENERALLY WITH VACCINE ROLLOUT
SOME COUNTIES WORKED WELL EARLY
AND SOME. THE LADY FARMWORKER
VACCINE PROGRAMS. I DOES GET
AROUND IDEA OF BAD. RIGHT THANK
YOU SO I'D LIKE TO- THANK YOU.
AND JUST LET YOU KNOW THAT WE
ARE PROPOSING AMENDMENTS AS
WELL THAT WILL PROVIDE FOR
APPOINTMENT BY THE GOVERNOR.
THE SPEAKER AND THE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM AND ADD ADDITIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS TO THE EXISTING
LAST THANK YOU THANK THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH- LET'S MOVE ON
TO THIS NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT HER NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
LET'SBEGIN WITH THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE OR THE PUBLIC
GALLERY LET'S MISTER IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN C. KNOWN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR WITNESSES WHO
SHOULD TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE FIVE EIGHT AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FIVE FIVE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. AND LINE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN IN MY COULD UP WITH.
GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT LINE. BLIGHTED TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BLOODY HEAVY EVENT WHAT CENTRAL
VALLEY IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION
COLLABORATIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU EXCELLENT. WHY TWENTY
EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NOTIFIED IMOLA
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION PROUD TO
SPONSOR AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE WEST MEDICAL COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY THREE OF
MY KIDS UP. HE DID CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JOHN EIGHTEEN THAT I'LL
BE OUT OF LUCK WITH YOUR
COMPANY YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE YOUR BIKE IS UP.
BLIND ONE HUNDRED FORTY NINE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. BLIGHTED
THIRTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO LOUI GET A LITTLE FROM
BUILDINGS LEGAL CENTRE IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND COACHELLA
VALLEY AND STRONG SUPPORTER SB
FIVE FIVE EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HI THIS IS THE ANY WAY
OUT OF FROM MERCER COUNTY AND
TRUMP SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. AND MISTER KERR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THAT TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE DO
NOT HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS TO TESTIFY. SO WILL NOW
MOVE INTO OPPOSITION FOR SB
FIVE FIVE EIGHT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WERE PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON THE PUBLIC GALLERY
LET'S MOVE THROUGH TWENTY FORTY
SEEN ON ROUTE TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. FIVE FIVE
EIGHT YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. FIVE FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND A LINE OF ONE
HUNDRED FORTY NINE YOUR BIKE IN
THE. HELLO HERE CAME EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
URBAN INSTITUTE WE ARE ACTUALLY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED A
CARD NUMBER RIGHT BEING A J.
YOU WILL REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT
AND- IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT. WE ALSO
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN. OKAY
YES- MY NAME IS MARCO IT IS
OUR- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
RECOMMENDED THE- CAMPESINA WE
ARE CURRENTLY SERVING-
FARMWORKERS REQUIRED NEW
VENTURES FOR MISTER FARMWORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THE
FULL SUPPORT OF SB FIVE PART.
TIME SENATOR COMING YEAR. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
A ANY WITNESS AND OP. TO ASK
FIVE EIGHT. YEARS NUMBER STOP
ASSERTION. AND MISTER KERR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW LET'S MOVE TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY I
DON'T SEE ANY- SO SECOND AT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF AND- TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND AGAIN I THINK
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING IN THIS
BILL WE DID WANT TO BE. I
THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE TO WORK WITH OUR
DISASTER FOLKS OVER E. AT- YES
BUT I THINK CERTAINLY DIRECTOR
SENATE REPORT ROLE FOR THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WELL
GIVEN THE TYPES OF THINGS ARE
LOOKING AT. BUT TO BE VERY
SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AND I DO AGREE
WITH YOU RIGHT IT PROBABLY IS
MORE APPROPRIATELY AND- YES AND
I THINK- WHAT REALLY MAGNIFIES
THIS IS IN THE MIDDLE OF. THE
RISING- IT INFECTION RATE AMONG
FARMWORKERS IN AT THE END OF
THE SUMMER- WE SAW HUGE RISE AT
THE SAME TIME THAT WE SAW A-
INCREDIBLE- WILDFIRE. IN
CATASTROPHE HAPPENING THE AIR
QUALITY WAS HORRIBLE EVERYBODY
WAS TOLD TO STAY INDOORS AND
FARMWORKERS WERE LEFT OUTSIDE
WORKING. IN SOME PRETTY
UNTENABLE CONDITIONS IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN GOOD TO HAVE A PLAN
AND TO KNOW HOW TO EXECUTE THAT
PLAN SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR AVAIL IS OUR MOST I SEE
EMOTION FROM CENTER ROCK SERAP
IS MOVED TO BUILD THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
REMANDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES-
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S. EGGMAN
HI EGGMAN AIKEN SALAS HI
CONSULTS I'D GROW HER TADO. FOR
TOTAL AYE LEYVA. LEYVA. AYE
LIMóN. THE EMAIL S. FIVE FIVE
EIGHT HI. LIMON ROTH ROTH AYE
RUBIO HI RUBIO WIENER OUR
WIENER I. THE CARD ROLE IS NINE
KERN VOTE NINE ZERO PUT THE
BILL CALL THANKS VERY MUCH HE
SAID RIGHT NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SB SIX OH FIVE BY CENTER EGGMAN
I BELIEVE YOU PERCENT FOR YOUR
DESK CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
EXCUSE ME HI LIKE A LOT OF US I
THINK I'M SUFFERING FROM
ALLERGIES TODAY SO PLEASE BEAR
WITH ME. I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE CODE
ON THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR WORK. THOUGHTFUL AND
DILIGENT IN NOT WORKING ON THIS
AND- AND I AM ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESSED THE
ISSUES LAID OUT IN THE
ANALYSIS. I DON'T WANT TO
DISTRACT TOO MUCH FROM THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL WHICH IS
VERY TARGETED AND SPECIFIC. BUT
I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY MENTION
KIND OF THE BROADER ISSUE ON
RIGHT TO REPAIR IF YOU'VE BEEN-
OVERWHELMED WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL YOU MIGHT THINK
WHAT WHAT IS THIS BILL DOING
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
OPPOSING WELL. IT'S A LOT IT'S
THIS IS A MOVEMENT THAT'S BEEN
WORKING AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
SO THERE'S INTEREST IN IT- A
PEOPLE MAY RECALL I'VE WORKED
IN THIS SPACE. FOR A WHILE AND
THEN THE ISSUE IS JUST THIS
WHEN. WHEN CORPORATIONS. SELL
US A PRODUCT DO WE OWN IT OR DO
THEY OWN IT AND IF WE OWN IT
MAY WE GET IT REPAIRED. BY
SOMEBODY OTHER THAN THE COMPANY
WHO SOLD IT TO US. I UNDERSTAND
THAT'S THEIR BUSINESS MODEL BUT
WE NEED TO QUESTION I THINK
THERE'S A BUSINESS MODEL WORK
FOR. EVERYDAY PEOPLE. DOES IT
WORK FOR IN THISCASE HOSPITALS
DOES IT WORK FOR PATIENTS. AND
DOESN'T WORK FOR REPAIR PEOPLE
WHO ARE QUALIFIED. A LOT OF
THEM SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ENTREPRENEURS- SO THAT'S THAT'S
THE QUESTION BEFORE US TODAY
AND IF YOU'RE WONDERING WHY
THERE WAS SO MUCH OPPOSITION.
THAT'S WHY- EVERYONE BANDS
TOGETHER TO TRY TO STOP
SOMETHING THEY THINK MIGHT HURT
THEIR BUSINESS MODEL- THE
FUNDAMENTAL GOALS OF THE RIGHT
TO REPAIR MOVEMENT ARE TO
REDUCE WASTE. INCREASE
COMPETITION FOR REPAIR TO
SUPPORT LOCAL BUSINESSES.
IMPROVE PRODUCT DURABILITY AND
RESTORE WHAT IT TRULY MEANS. TO
OWN OUR OWN STUFF I THINK WE
CAN ALL. AGREE WITH THOSE
PRINCIPLES- AND OUR
CONVERSATION IS TODAY WILL THIS
MOVEMENT IS HAPPENING AROUND
THE COUNTRY. IT IS HOW DO WE
TRANSFERRED THESE PRINCIPLES.
INTO PUBLIC POLICY. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON. TODAY M.
THE BILL TAKES A SIMPLE
APPROACH LOOKING JUST ONE
CATEGORY PRODUCTS MEDICAL
DEVICES AND TRIES TO OPEN UP
THE REPAIR MARKET BY ALLOWING
ACCESS TO THE NEEDED PARTS
TOOLS DOCUMENTATION AND
SOFTWARE FOR MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR RIGHT NOW IT IS LEGAL
FOR THE HOSPITAL TO REPAIR
THEIR OWN EQUIPMENT OR FOR
SOMEBODY THEY CONTRACT WITH TO
REPAIR EQUIPMENT THAT THE
HOSPITAL HAS PURCHASED THAT THE
HOSPITAL OWNS. BUT SUFFERS IS
PUT INTO PLACE- THE STOP AT THE
REPAIRS CAN IN FACT JUST SHUT
DOWN A DEVICE IF IT IS NOT
REPAIRED BY THE MANUFACTURER-
AND- THERE IS NOT ENOUGH ACCESS
T PARTS THE TOOLS. THE
DOCUMENTATION. AS OPPOSED TO BE
AMENDED ACCESS TO THESE
RESOURCES. SPITTLE ON THE
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR OF THEIR
EQUIPMENT. REPORTING EARLY ON
IN THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC I
THINK HIGHLIGHTED JUST NOT JUST
THE LACK OF INVESTMENT IN
SUPPLY AND EQUIPMENT STOCKPILES
BUT THE CHALLENGES PRESENT AND
TRYING TO REPAIR MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT. AND I THINK THE KEY
TAKEAWAY IS THAT THIS IS NOT A
PROBLEM BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
BUT IT WAS AN EXISTING PROBLEM
LIKE A LOT OF THINGS MADE
VISIBLE TO US BY THE PANDEMIC.
HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA MAY
EMPLOY IN HOUSE BIOMEDICAL
ENGINEERS AND TAX AND THEY MAY
WORK WITH INDEPENDENT SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS ON ALA CARTE OR
CONTRACT BASIS THESE ARE
PROFESSIONALS WHO WORK ON
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT FOR A LIVING.
STOP TO THINK ABOUT THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WE RUN
INTO UST TRYING TO USE
TECHNOLOGY TO RUN A COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR EXAMPLE AND YOU CAN
APPRECIATE WHY IS IMPORTANT FOR
HOSPITALS TO HAVE PEOPLE READY
THERE TO BE ABLE TO FIX THINGS.
THESE PROFESSIONALS HAVE
IDENTIFIED THE MANUFACTURE
CREATED BARRIERS TO REPAIR IS
CRUCIAL HINDRANCE IN THEIR WORK
AND TO PATIENT CARE LAST SPRING
IN A SURVEY OF BIO MED'S. U. S.
PARADE FOUND THAT 92% OF
RESPONDENTS REPORTED THEY HAD
BEEN DENIED ACCESS TO SERVICE
INFORMATION FOR CRITIC CRITICAL
EQUIPMENT. 30% REPORTED
EQUIPMENT IN THEIR FACILITIES
THAT THE DATE COULD NOT BE USED
DUE TO RESTRICTIONS ON SPARE
PARTS AND SERVICE INFORMATION.
AND NEARLY 70% OF RESPONDENTS
SAID THEIR HOSPITAL HAS HAD TO
DELAY. A PATIENT PROCEDURE
BECAUSE THEY WERE WAITING ON A
MANUFACTURER SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVE TO FIX A DEVICE.
THE SURVEY NUMBERS HELP PAINT A
PICTURE. THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS WHO SUPPORT THIS THIS
EFFORT AND REPORT THAT
MANUFACTURES OFTEN UNABLE TO
SERVICE EQUIPMENT AT THE TIME
FRAME NEEDED AND THE HOSPITAL'S
TEAM MUST DECIDE BETWEEN TAKING
A MACHINE THAT IS DUE FOR
REGULAR MAINTENANCE OFFLINE. OR
NOT HAVING MET ITS MAINTENANCE
SCHEDULE. WHO IS THE SERVICE
WHO BENEFIT FROM HOSPITAL'S
MACHINES GOING OFFLINE OR
MISSING MAINTENANCE EXPERTS ON
THE SCENE OR DENIED THE TOOLS
PARTS AND INFORMATION THEY NEED
TO DO THEIR JOBS. THE OPPONENTS
WILL ARGUE THAT THIS EQUIPMENT
IS TOO COMPLICATED THE ONLY
THEIR TRAIN PEOPLE CAN REPAIR
THEM. BUT THE WRIST CARE REALLY
FALLS ON THE PATIENTS IN
HOSPITALS WHO RELY ON THESE
MACHINES. AND CONSUMER
ADVOCATES AND HEALTH PROVIDERS
AGREE THAT THIS BILL WOULD HELP
THEM. I THINK THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES THAT A GREAT JOB
BREAKING DOWN THE FINDINGS OF
THE FDA REPORT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. SO JUST HIGHLIGHT
THAT THIS AFTER EXTENSIVE
REVIEW THEY DID NOT BELIEVE
THAT A SAFETY PROBLEM EXIST.
WITH THE SERVICING MANY
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR OF
MEDICAL DEVICES BY EITHER THIRD
PARTY ORGANIZATIONS. OR
MANUFACTURERS. IT'S IMPORTANT
ENOUGH RIGHT THAT WAS FTA
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'LL HEAR
FROM THE OPPOSITION OF THE FTA
SAID THERE'S ALL THESE PROBLEMS
THEY DID NOT BELIEVE THAT A
SAFETY PROBLEM EXIST WITH THE
SERVICING. MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR OF MEDICAL DEVICES BUT
YOU THE THIRD PARTY THE
ORGANIZATIONS OR MANUFACTURERS.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLYREQUIRING
THAT THE SAME PARTS TOOLS
INFORMATION SOFTWARE AND
TRAINING AVAILABLE TO
MANUFACTURERS AUTHORIZED REPAIR
NETWORK. ALSO BE AVAILABLE TO
THOSE THIRD. PARTIES AN IN
HOUSE ENGINEERS WORKING ON THIS
CRITICAL EQUIPMENT. WHEN
DEVICES GO OFFLINE AND CARES
DELAYED ITS PATIENTS THAT
SUFFER. THIS BILL CAN INCREASE
PUMP COMPETITION HOPEFULLY
REDUCE COSTS AND HELP PEOPLE.
IGNORE LOGIC THERE ARE PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO CAN FIX THINGS
WHOSE JOB IT IS TO FIX THINGS.
AND SAYS THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THE RIGHT PARTS.
TOOLS AND DOCUMENTS TRACING TO
THEY CAN SAFELY AND TIMELY DO
THAT. I'D ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND
WITH ME TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
IS KEVIN O. RILEY WITH U. S.
PURRING IN. MOTHER HAMMOND A
SEASONED CLINICAL. ENGINEERING
MANAGER OF TWENTY YEARS. THANK
YOU CENTER EGGMAN MODERATOR CAN
PLEASE BRING ONLINE FOR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT KEVIN O.
RILEY FROM U. S. PERK AND IN
THE DARK. HAMID CLINICAL.
ENGINEERING MANAGER. AND WILL
BEGIN WITH- KEVIN A RILEY AND
JUST REMINDER FOR. BOTH OF YOU-
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES APIECE OR
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES SO IF- KEVIN
A RILEY GOES OVER THAT CUTS
INTO THE FOUR MINUTES- SO IF-
CAN RILEY'S READY- PLEASE BEGIN.
GREAT THANK YOU CHAIR CAN A
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S KEVIN O. RILEY I NAY
RIGHT TO REPAIR ADVOCATE WITH
US PURGING CAL PERCOCO
SPONSORED THE BILL.
MANUFACTURERS ROUTINELY
RESTRICT HOSPITAL IN
INDEPENDENT BIOMEDICAL REPAIR
TECHNICIANS ARE BY A MESSAGE
FROM ACCESSING ESSENTIAL OKAY
MATERIALS. AT THE OUTSET OF THE
PANDEMIC WIPES MARCH ONE
INDEPENDENT SERVICE
ORGANIZATION RECEIVED A HUNDRED
VENTILATORS FROM THE HOSPITALS
THAT WORKS WITH. DEFENSE NEED
ROUTINE MAINTENANCE AND TESTING
BEFORE THEY COULD BE PUT TO USE
BUT THE MANUFACTURER IF USED TO
SELL THE INDEPENDENT THE KIDS
NEEDED TO DO THIS SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY WERE A THIRD
PARTY. AS A RESULT IT WAS MORE
THAN FOUR MONTHS BEFORE THE
HOSPITALS WERE ABLE TO PUT THAT
IN A LETTER FROM THE TRUCK
STRATEGIC STOCKPILE AND USE.
FOUR MONTHS OF THE COULD NOT BE
USED TO TREAT COPD PATIENTS.
PATIENTS DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE
CLOSE TO THAT MUCH OF THE
WEIGHT ESPECIALLY DURING A
PANDEMIC AND THIS DOESN'T JUST
HAPPEN WITHIN A LEADERS ARE
JUST HAPPEN WITHIN AN
INDEPENDENT SERVICE PROVIDERS.
IT'S NO WONDER THE BILL AS
RECEIVED SUCH STRONG SUPPORT
FROM HOSPITALS PARTICULARLY IN
RURAL COUNTIES THAT OFTEN
EXPERIENCE LONGER. WAITS FOR
MANUFACTURE TECHNICIANS. MANY
FACTORS ARE. THAT WHILE THE NOT.
ASPECTS OF THE- IT IS A BIT NOW.
NOT ONE TO PROTECT PROTECT US.
BUT WE CAN'T IGNORE THE DAMAGE
REPAIRS FRICTIONS THE PATIENTS
OR THE FACT THAT IT RAISES THE
COST HEALTHCARE- TAKE SAFETY
CONCERNS SERIOUSLY SO WE LOOKED
AT THE DATA AND IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AT THE A REPORT TO THE
CENTRE MENTION. IT STATED THAT
MANY THIRD PARTY ENTITIES
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE SERVICING ON MEDICAL
DEVICES. AND THAT THE CONTINUED
AVAILABILITY OF THIRD PARTY
ENTITIES TO SERVICE AND REPAIR
MEDICAL DEVICES IS CRITICAL TO
THE FUNCTIONING OF THE U. S.
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. THAT'S WHY
WE AND OTHER CONSUMER AND
PUBLIC HEALTH GROUPS SUPPORT SB
SIX OH FIVE. AT CYBER SECURITY
GOES EXPERTS AGREE THAT REPAIR
ACCESS IS NOT LEAD TO INCREASE
ON OUR ABILITIES. THE BEST
PRACTICES FOR SECURING DATA AND
DEVICES DOESN'T INVOLVE WALKING
A REPAIR. SB SIX OH FIVE WILL
HELP PATIENTS IN HOSPITALS IN
EVERY CORNER CALIFORNIA. EXPECT
WE ASK YOU TO BUT I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU LET'S NOW
BRING THAT ARE HAMMERED- AND
YOU HAVE ACTUALLY TWO MINUTES
AND NINE SECONDS HE GIVE YOU
LOOKS TIME. BUT THANK YOU HELLO
MY NAME IS ANOTHER HOME WITH-
CLINT ENGINEERING MANAGER AT
THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM OF
HOSPITALS. I HAVE OVER TWENTY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN THIS
JOB. THANK YOU FOR THE PERSON
TO SPEAK ABOUT WHY MEDICAL.
RIGHT TO REPAIR S CRITICAL FOR
CALIFORNIA. MANUFACTURER IMPOSE
BARRIERS TO FIXING MEDICAL
DEVICES IN MIND THE STATE HAS
BEEN ENTIRE PROBLEM DURING THE
PANDEMIC BUT IT'S NOT SOMETHING
YOU. MULTIPLE TIMES THROUGHOUT
MY CAREER I'VE HAD TO COME INTO
THE HOSPITAL IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT THE EARLY MORNING THE
TRIED TO PULL PARTS FROM
DIFFERENT RESOURCES DIFFERENT
EQUIPMENT. THE REPETITIVE THE
DEVICE TO MAKE SURE I'S
AVAILABLE FOR PATIENT CARE
BECAUSE THAT PERSON WAS AT
FATAL RISK. IN THOSE MOMENTS WE
DIDN'T HAVE DAYS OR WEEKS TO
WAIT FOR THE MANUFACTURERS
RESPONDED WITH THE FLU THROUGH
THAT PROCESS AS EFFICIENT
NEEDED THAT DEVISED BY THE WAY
FISHABLE MONTH WAIT. AND SUCH
CASES THAT ABILITY FOR VITAMINS
AND HOUSE THE QUICKLY AND SEE
IF THEY'RE BETTER CRITICAL
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT. CAN BE A
MATTER OF LIFE. OR DEATH.
LITERALLY THEY GIVING US AT TO
AN S. BEEN. AND INFORM. THIS
BILL WOULD. DELAYS AND
PROFICIENT AND SAY. AND OTHER
TIME A GROUP. COSTS OF
HEALTHCARE. THIS HAPPENS WEBER
SERVE IN HOUSE AND SIMPLY
INJECTING COMPETITION INTO THE
MEDICAL REPAIR MARC PLACE. WE
CAN REDUCE OVERHEAD AND PASS
THOSE SAVINGS ON TO THE
PATIENTS. ON THE IDEA THAT
BENEFIT OUT. TO SERVICEMEN WENT.
AND THEY'RE ONLY WILL THEY'RE
THE ONLY ONES QUALIFIED IT'S
NOT ACCURATE AND THIS NONSENSE
THE BIOMEDICAL ENGINEERS ON MY
TEAM AND HAD UNDER SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE UTILIZE
AND WORK WITH. WE EARNED
DEGREES AND CERTIFICATIONS
UNDERGARMENT THAT THROUGH
CONTINUOUS CONTINUED EDUCATION
HOSPITAL IN CALIFORNIA HOLISTIC
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS SET BY
THE CENTER FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID. CMS SET BY THE JOINT
COMMISSION AND BY BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. STATUS THROUGH WHETHER
OUR SERVICE IS DONE IN HOUSE OR
BY AN INDEPENDENT PARTY- NUMBER
ONE CONCERN IS ALWAYS EFFICIENT
SAFETY THE WRITER BETTER
MEDICAL DEVICES WILL ALLOW US
TO TREAT PATIENTS QUICKLY AND
SAFELY. WHILE ALSO REDUCING
HEALTHCARE COSTS THIS IS WHY WE
SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
VOTE ON SB SIX OH FIVE. AND I.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
THANK THANK YOU ALL RIGHT-
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT OF SB SIX
OH FIVE- SO THIS NAME OR EXIST
POSITION ONLY WILL BEGIN THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON PUBLIC
ELLIS MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEN ON ROUTE TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
TELEPHONIC LINE TO WITNESSES
WHO IS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX ZERO FIVE AND AGAIN IT'S
NAME OR EXHORTATION POSITION
ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT SB SIX OH
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE. AND
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. AND A LINE THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE YOUR BIKE AT THE-
END OF THE DAY IN OUR
CERTIFICATION REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. FIND ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS TO
BAND REPRESENTING WASHINGTON
HOSPITAL HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX OH FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LINE TWENTY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD AFFECT. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR ALEX HAWTHORN AT THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE THREE HUNDRED SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS THERE BUT ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. ONE THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE YOUR MIKE AT THE-
KEVIN MEMBER KEVIN AGAIN SAYS
THE CORBIN KINDER ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
FIVE THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. YES
HELLO MY NAME SORRY FORTUNE I'M
NOT BUYING THAT MEDICAL
ENGINEER FROM A SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA HOSPITAL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. SB SIX OH
FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT SLIDE.
LINE THREE HUNDRED FIVE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. I'M COMFORTABLE
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH AT THE
CATALOGUE SANDERS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX SO FAR
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LIVE THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. RICHARD FLANNERY
PRESIDENT OF METEOROLOGICAL
SERVICES SERVING CALIFORNIA
BUDGET VISION OF AMERICAN
MEDICAL IMAGING I STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE SENATE BILL SIX OH
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
SLIDE. LINE THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY YOUR MY KIDS UP. MY NAME
IS NICOLE PALMER VICE PRESIDENT
OF OPERATIONS FOR MULTI MEDICAL
SYSTEM AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN YOUR
MIKE AT THE. YES MY NAME IS
OVERSEE A DIRECTOR BILL SERVICE
FOR MULTI MEDICAL SYSTEMS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. APPLY TO
ONE HUNDRED NINETY TWO YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. MY NAME IS
RELAXING CLINICAL ENGINEERING
MANAGER. AND SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB SIX O'CLOCK THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. A LINE OF THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
MY NAME IS DAN LARA BIOMED I
SUPPORT THIS. L. SIX OH FIVE
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THE LINE
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY NINE YOUR
MIND IS OPEN. THIS IS MICHAEL
MCROBERTS HEREBY CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT FOR MULTI MEDICAL
SYSTEMS I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIX YOUR MY
COULD OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
JESSICA VERY NICE SUPPORT A
STEP BE SIX OH FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. EXLINE BY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD UP. REGAL RIVER SEVEN
CALIFORNIA HAS A PERMANENT BAN
MANAGER IMAGING SERVICES AND I
SUPPORT SB SIX ZERO FIVE. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. ONE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT YOU'RE
LIKE IT'S UP. MARIN MAHONEY ON
BEHALF OF CONSUMER REPORTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE OF THREE HUNDRED TWO YOUR
MIKE ABOUT THE. LINE THREE
HUNDRED TWO YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN PLEASE CHECK FOR ME.
BLIGHTED THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. THEN
DUBLIN UCSF CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL- MITCHELL PART OF THIS
BE SIX OH FIVE. THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. BLIGHTED SEVENTY
THREE YEAR MIKE IS UP. MY NAME
IS JENNIFER KILL ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT QUALITY WITH
NORTHFIELD MEDICAL AND A MEMBER
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF MEDICAL
DEVICE SERVICE ORGANIZATION AND
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS STRONG
SUPPORT SB SIX OH FIVE. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT- MY KIDDO. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M DARYN KNEELING PRESIDENT OF
MULTI MEDICAL SYSTEMS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANKS LINE. WHY
TO ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. MY NAME
IS DAVID DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR
OF OPERATIONS FOR CENTER
HEALTHY CLIP AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB SIX ACQUIRED THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE THREE
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT YOUR MIGHT
DEVELOP. JORDAN WELLS ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX OH FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. A LINE OF THREE
HUNDRED FORTY NINE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. CAREER MIKE ABOUT
HI THIS IS STEPHEN GRIMES.
DAHLE FOR QUALITY. TRUMP'S BASE
GEN I THANK YOU MARK NEXT LINE.
WHY IN THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HELLO
QUALITY TAKES CURRENT ONE A
COASTAL SB SIX OH FIVE HI THE
SHORTLIST NEED TO SUBORDINATE
IMPORTANT THE BELLS. AFTER
COLLEGE OF CLINICAL ENGINEER. I
THINK SET EMERICA BATTERY OF
COUNTY AND YOU EMPLOYEES AFSCME
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
THE CALIFORNIA BLACK HELP
NETWORK CALIFORNIA HEALTH
ADVOCATES. CALIFORNIA STATE
LAUREL HEALTH ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
CONSUMER ACTION FIX IT CLINIC
REPAIR .ORG SECURE REPAIR
SUBJECT SO THE STORY OF STUFF
PROJECT AN UPSTREAM HE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. AND MAKING
SURE THERE ARE NO COM AT THE
TIME ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
NOW MOVES TO OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY- THERE TWO. WITNESSES
WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING AT
FORMALLY IN OPPOSITION THAT WE
HAVE FIELDING GREENS FROM
ADVAMED ADVANCED MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND
RANDY MATHIS FOR PHILIPS NORTH
AMERICA AND- SO JUST A
REMINDER- YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES ARE ACTUALLY TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES SO I'LL GIVE YOU A TWO
MINUTE WARNING- BUT IF YOU GO
OVER. FEELING GRIEVES- THAT
THEN THEY'LL BE LESS TIME FOR
RANDY MATHIS SO PLEASE BRING
THEM ON THE LINE AND FIELDING
GREASE PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS FEELING RECENTLY DANCE
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY POST THE BILL.
PATIENT SAFETY IS AT THE HEART
OF EVERYTHING WE DO IN THE
MEDICAL DEVICE COMMUNITIES
AMONG MOST HEAVILY REGULATED IN
THE WORLD. ADMINISTRATION
REGULATE EVERYTHING WE DO FOR
ITS QUALITY SYSTEM REGULATION
THAT COVERS ALL ASPECTS OF
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY. U. S.
MARKET SERVICE REPAIR CYBER
SECURITY FOR CONNECTED DEVICES.
MEMBERS WE SEE NO CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE OF SYSTEMIC SHORTAGES
OR DELAYS IN REPAIRS BUT
RESPECTED VENTILATORS OR OTHER
EQUIPMENT GENERALLY ARE DURING
THE PANDEMIC NO COMPLAINTS
ABOUT REPAIR DELAYS A LARGE THE
PFT OR HHS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
NO CREDIBLE NATURALLY OCCURRING
NEWS STORIES REPORTED THE ISSUE
AS ME NOW ALSO POINTS OUT
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT COMPETITION
IN THE SPACE BETWEEN SIXTEEN
AND TWENTY THOUSAND INDEPENDENT
SERVICE ORGANIZED. ORGANIZATION
UNITED STATES. YESTERDAY YES
THE REPORT ACTUALLY STATES THAT
AND I QUOTE THE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE OBJECTIVE EVIDENCE
NOT SUFFICIENT TO CONCLUDE
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS
WIDESPREAD PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERN REALLY SERVICING. BUT
OTHER EVIDENCE AND WORK OF THE
FDA POINTS OUT PROBLEMS
INCLUDING AT THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT DOCUMENTED. CASES OF
INJURIES AND DEATHS. SIR ORDER
AND BY AND ARE NOW REGULATE FOR
MEDICAL REPAIR NOT BY THE FDA
NOT BY THE- ONLY MY WASTE. ARE
REGULATED MEDICAL DEVICE
REPAIRS BY THE FDA RETIRING
ACCORDING TO THE COMPANY'S GIVE
OVER EVERYTHING WILL ONLY
INCREASE THE USE OF FUND
REGULATE TECHNICIAN WITH
INCREASED RISK. PATIENT
CLOTHING INJURIES AND DEATHS IN
THE NAME OF COST SAVINGS. IF
THE STATE IS GOING TO CREATE A
RIGHT TO REPAIR I MIGHT SUGGEST
THAT YOU START WITH THE
SANDWICHING A MEDICAL DEVICE
SERVICING AND REPAIR LICENSE
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. WITH
APPROPRIATE TRAINING EXPERIENCE
REQUIREMENTS FOR A VARIETY OF
PRODUCTS SENATORS IT'S AN
EXTREMELY COMPLEX ISSUE IN THE
FDA IN CONGRESS NEEDS RESOLVE
IT BY CREATING A COMPLETE
REGULATED ECOSYSTEM OVERSIGHT
AND TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN ALL
PARTIES. THIS BILL MAKE THINGS
WORSE CAUSE CONFUSION GREAT
LAWSUITS PUSH. UP COSTS.
INSTEAD FURTHER RISK I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO READ
MATH SAID- MISTER GREASED LEFT
YET GAVE YOU- NECK FIVE SECONDS
ON TOP YOUR TWO MINUTES. PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RANDY
MATHIS AND THE DISTRICT SERVICE
MANAGER FOR PHILLIPS.
HEALTHCARE TECHNOLOGY COMPANY
THAT MANUFACTURES A VARIETY OF
MEDICAL DEVICES INCLUDING MRI.
CT CAP LABS X. THREE AND MORE.
I'VE BEEN WITH BILLS SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY AND I CURRENTLY
OVERSEE DIAGNOSTIC IMAGING
SERVICE DELIVERY ACROSS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. I'VE
WORKED IN THE INDUSTRY FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS STARTING IN THE
BIO MED FOR THE MILITARY BUT
ALSO SERVED AS A FIELD ENGINEER
AS WELL AS THE TECHNICAL
SPECIALIST. WE WORK IN IT
INDUSTRY SHARE THE COMMON GOAL
OF DELIVERING THE HIGHEST
QUALITY OF HEALTH CARE
INCLUDING. HAVING ACCESS TO A
RELIABLE AND CLINICALLY
ACCURATE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT THE
CHEATING SKILLED CARPENTRY
SERVICE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
REQUIRED MORE THAN HAVING
ACCESS TO INSPECT INSTRUCTION
MANUALS AND DIAGNOSTIC
INFORMATION. IT TAKES A
COMBINATION OF TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLING TECHNICAL TRAINING
MENTORSHIP CONTINUING EDUCATION
AND TOTAL IMMERSION IN THE
PRODUCT. I AM CONCERNED THAT
THIS BILL GIVES VIRTUALLY
ANYONE THE TWO INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY AND TAXES NEEDED TO
TINKER WITH ANY MEDICAL DEVICE.
REGARDLESS OF EXPERIENCE IN
TRAINING AND WITHOUT INSURANCE
TO REGULATORY CONTROLS AND
OVERSIGHT. SPECIFICALLY THERE
IS NO REGULATION OF
UNAUTHORIZED INDEPENDENT
SERVICE PROVIDERS THERE IS NO
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
TRAINED. THE QUALITY OF THEIR
WORK IN THE PARK THE USE. IN
THE WORLD HIGH PRESSURE MEDICAL
SERVICE DELIVERY PEOPLE MAY
UNKNOWINGLY OR KNOWINGLY
OVERSTEPPED THEIR TRAIN
CAPABILITIES. OR COMPROMISE
STANDARDS RESULTING IN
DECREASED SERVICE QUALITY AND.
INCREASED PATIENT THANK YOU
READ. THE CONCERN REMARKETING.
THE SYSTEM EXISTS ALREADY GIVE
HIGH. CHOICES IN HEALTH FILE
MEDICARE AUTHOR I THIRD PARTY
SERVICE. CURRENTLY HAVE THE
UPPER. TO ENTRY ALONG OF OUR
ENGINEER. AND OBTAIN THE DIE.
TOOLS AND TECHNICAL
DOCUMENTATION NEEDED TO RESOLVE
ISSUES TO CONCLUDE WE SHOULD
ALWAYS STRIVE TO IMPROVE HEALTH
CARE QUALITY AND PATIENT
SAFETY. BUT THIS BILL IS THE
MOVE BACKWARD BY CREATING A
PROCESS THAT WOULD ALLOW
SOMEONE WHO MAY LACK THE RIGHT
EXPERTISE TO CERTAIN COMPLEX
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT. WITHOUT ANY
OVERSIGHT OR REGULATION FOR
THESE REASONS I ASK YOU. TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE
WHAT IN OPPOSITION TO SBSIX OH
FIVE FOLD BEGIN WITH THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SAY NO AT THE PUBLIC
ELLIS MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SAY NO IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX ZERO FIVE WE GET ITS
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO THAT
WOULD BE SIX OH FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE. BUTTON ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND
THAT LINE FORTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. UNDER SECRETARY OF
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES ASSOCIATION AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE ITSELF THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. WHITE A ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD UP. HM BAPTIZED IN STRONG
OPPOSITION SB SIX OH FIVE.
THANK YOU NEXT NEXT- LINE. LINE
TWO HUNDRED NINETY THREE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. THANK YOU YOUR
NUMBER LARRANAGA ARE THE
HOSPITALIZED EC IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. LLOYD DATE NOVEMBER
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OF
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. ONE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE YEAR MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS DON CLAY BACK
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
COALITION FOR ASSISTED AND WE
HAVE TECHNOLOGY- SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX OH FIVE.
THANK YOU THANKS LINE. CLYDE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE- MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SCHERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SUPPORT FOR THAT MAKE ON BEHALF
OF THE MEDICAL IMAGING AND
TECHNOLOGY ALLIANCE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE THREE HUNDRED FORTY TWO
YOU'RE MY COULD HELP. GIVE ME
JACKSON VIACOM CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WINDS
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT- MY
COULD OPEN. THE CURRENT MEMBERS
BOB ACKERMAN AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION MEDICAL
PRODUCTS SUPPLIERS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME
OKAY THANK YOU- THAT LET'S MOVE
IT BACK TO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEND RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- YOU KNOW OKAY GONNA
THINK EVERYONE WHO TESTIFIED IN
FAVOR AND OPPOSE- I'M TAKING
YOUR COMMENTS VERY SERIOUSLY
AND NOW THIS IS. A MEDICAL
DEVICE CLARITY THAT THE NATURE
OF THIS BILL IS VERY SENSITIVE
AND IT SAVES LIVES BUT IT COULD
ALSO POTENTIALLY. GO THE OTHER
DIRECTION SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY A FEW THINGS IF I MAY-
WELL FIRST OF ALL I JUST HEARD
THE AUTHOR STATES THAT THE
THERE ISN'T A REPORT BY THE FDA
THAT- STATES THAT. THEY DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S A SAFETY
PROBLEM THAT EXISTED FOR THIRD
PARTY FIXES THESE MACHINES-
WELL FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
ASK IF I CAN. HAVE YOUR STUFF
THEN THAT REFER TO BECAUSE I
WOULD LIKE TO READ IT BUT-
SECONDLY. ALONG THOSE LINES I
ALSO HEARD BE OPPOSITION STATE
THAT THE FD EIGHT. HEAVILY
REGULATES THEM SO I JUST KIND
pABOUT THAT PART THE REGULATION
PART OF THE FTA IS NOT
REGULATING. FOR HAVING THE
OVERSIGHT WHO WOULD TAKE OVER
THE OVERSIGHT AND BE. ON TOP OF
THESE ISSUES IF I CAN HAVE THAT
ANSWER THANK YOU. THE SO THAT
THE FDA REPORT IS. I CAN I CAN
SEND YOU A COPY BUT IT IS
DETAILED THROUGH AND SIX
THROUGH EIGHT. OF THE ANALYSIS
IT'S A- IS THERE- SO AS AS AS
DAY AS EVERYONE HAS SAID THIS
IS ALREADY REGULATED THE THIRD
PARTY PEOPLE ARE ALREADY DOING
THIS THE HOSPITALS ARE ALREADY
DOING THIS THE SAME PLACE THAT
THE COMPANY MIGHT GET THEIR
CERTIFICATES I MEAN THESE ARE
STANDARD RIGHT WE HEARD FROM
THE WITNESS SAID THAT THE
THOUGHT TO THE FDA AND CMS
DEPENDING ON THE SYSTEM WHILST
STILL REGULATES IS STILL
REGULATED- SO IT DOES SO THAT
HASN'T CHANGED WHAT WHAT THIS
BILL AND TRIES TO DO AS AS YOU
HAVE HEARD PEOPLE LIKE WILL
CLOSE DOWN THE SOFTWARE. WILL
NOT LET YOU HAVE PARTS WILL
SOMETIMES PUT THE DEVICE IT IN
OFTEN USABLE IF THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN THE ONES TO WORK ON IT
VETERANS STUFF TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN UP MORE TO THINK AND THESE
KINDS OF THINGS ARE ALREADY
HAPPENING AND SO IN CMS. IS A
REGULATING AGENCY. SO THAT SO
THAT DOESN'T CHANGE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWER- I
ALSO I THOUGHT I HEARD- THAT IF
THE HOSPITAL'S TAKEOVER THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE. THE
MANDATE- OF RECORDING DEBTS
MAYBE I HEARD IT WRONG AND I
KNOW THAT WHEN SPEAKERS SPEAK
AND IN FAVOR OR IN OPPOSITION
THEY'RE BRINGING AGAINST THE
TIME CLOCK IN THE TALK REALLY
FAST SO IF I MISS THAT I
APOLOGIZE CAN SOMEONE CLARIFY
THAT I THOUGHT I HEARD HIM SAY
THAT. YOU KNOW THE FDA REQUIRES
YOU TO A DOCUMENTATION AS IT
PERTAINS TO FATALITIES BUT NOT
IF THE MEDICAL HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATIONS HAVE TO KEEP
RECORDS OF THIS ANYBODY. VERIFY
THAT. OF SO SOMEBODY DYING A
DEVICE. THAT WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING. I AM GAP ASSERTION
STATED THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
KEEP THAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
KEEP RECORDS FOR THE FDA OF
FATALITIES OR- NOT RAINY DEBTS
BUT THAT IF THE- IF IT'S OUT OF
THEIR HANDS THAT. THE HOSPITALS
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO KEEP
RECORDS OF ANYBODY. A PASSING
BASED ON THESE EQUIPMENTS THAT
ARE REPAIRED I THINK WITH THEIR
I WOULD. I WOULDN'T LET MY
WITNESSES SPEAK BUT I WOULD
GUESS WHAT THEY'RE SPEAKING
ABOUT IS THAT OF SOMEBODY DIES
FROM A DEVICE THAT THE
MANUFACTURER HAS TO REPORT HOW
MANY DEATHS ARE CAUSED BY A
DEVICE. THAT THE I DON'T THINK
HAS ANYTHING TO DO WITH WHO HAS
WORKED ON THAT BUT ALL OF MY
WITNESSES ANSWER- SO IT.
ACTUALLY IS ONE OF THE-
PROPONENTS. CAN SPEAK TO THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS BY
HOSPITALS FOR ANY INJURY OR
DEATH CAUSED BY A DEVICE. HI
THIS IS NOT AT HOME WITH YES
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES
PLEASE IF YOU CONDUCT A GIVEN
YESTERDAY BUT I CAN DEFINITELY
SPEAK TO THAT- IN ANY CASES OF
INCIDENT THE WHETHER IT'S FATAL
OR NONFATAL- THE HOSPITAL'S
OBLIGATED TO REPORT TO THE FDA.
AND IT DEPENDS ON THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE EVENT IT
BECOMES MORE CRITICAL AND WE
HAVE THE REPORT IN A TIMELY
MANNER WE ARE REGULATED ON THAT
ASPECT AND WE REPORTED WE HAVE
A SYSTEM CALLED MET FUND IT'S
**** OF THE FDA SYSTEM. THAT WE
HAVE TO FOLLOW AND WE ARE
OBLIGATED SOMETHING OPTION. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE ARE AS WELL
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED THAT
WE ARE REGULATED BY CMS AND THE
JOINT COMMISSION WHICH CONTROLS
THE QUALITY AND THE
QUALIFICATION. OF THE PEOPLE
PERFORMING THE WORK. I HOPE
THIS ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION YES
AND THANK YOU LAST IF I MAY.
AND THIS GOES TO THE- THE ISSUE
OF BIOMEDICAL ENGINEERS ON
SITE- IN TERMS OF THEIR
EXPERTISE I'M SORRY I'M NOT AN
EXPERT SO I JUST KIND OF
WANTED. TO GET INTO A LITTLE
BIT OF THE TRANSFERENCE OF
EXPERTISE IS THERE. SORT OF A
TRIAL ERROR TIME WHERE YOU KNOW
IF THE IF THE HOSPITAL'S
TAKEOVER IF THE FIXING OF THE
MACHINES. HOW DO THEY GAIN
EXPERTISE DO THEY SPEND TIME
YOU KNOW WORKING ON IT AND I
YOU KNOW IF WE CAN ASK ONE OF
THE BIOMEDICAL ENGINEERS
BECAUSE I HEARD THAT. THROUGH
THE OPPOSITION THAT THEY SPEND
HOURS PRACTICING AND THEN
THERE'S CONTINUING EDUCATION I
MEAN I JUST FOR MY PEACE OF
MIND IS THERE. ANY YOU KNOW
FOLLOW UP EDUCATIONAL THOSE
MACHINES HOW TO BEGIN THAT
EXPERTISE. SO DO YOU WANT YES I
CAN ANSWER THAT AS WELL- AND
THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION. SO
WE HAVE A REQUIREMENT UNDER THE
CMS THE- ARTICLE FOUR EIGHTY TO
THE FORTY ONE B. ONE HI. AND
UNDER THE JOINT COMMISSION.
UNDER THE CHAPTER OF
ENVIRONMENT OF SCARCITY THAT
BOOK ONE BOOK ONE. WE ARE
REQUIRED. TO ONLY ALLOW
QUALIFIED PERSONNEL TO WORK ON
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT. AND PARTS OF
THIS BILL IS WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR. IS FOR THE MANUFACTURERS
TO ALLOW US TO BE TRAINED ON
THE SYSTEM WITHOUT BEING
BLOCKED. WE HAVE AN EX WE HAVE
A LIVE EXAMPLE IN MY DEPARTMENT
I SENT ONE OF MY ENGINEERS. TO
ACCOMPANY- WHICH WAS. WITNESSED
ON THE OPPOSITION AND WE WERE
TRAINED ON THE DEVICE AND THEY
SAID WE WILL ALLOW YOU TO WORK
ON THE DEVICE ONCE WE CAME
BACK. WE'RE TRYING TO FIX THE
DEVICE WHEN IT CAME ON PATIENT.
WE WERE SURPRISED THAT THE
LITTLE WALK BEHIND THE SERVICE
HE- RECALLED THE COMPANY WE
SAID. HEY WE WERE TRAINED YOU
GIVE US PERMISSION TO WORK ON
THE DEVICE BUT- NOW IT'S ASKING
ME FOR THE SERVICE HE CAN YOU
GIVE ME IS A RISKY THEY SAID NO
YOU HAVE TO SIGN A CONTRACT.
THEN WHY THE HECK DID I GET THE
SAME. SO THIS IS WHAT THEY'RE
ASKING FOR TRAINERS ALONG WITH
THE CONTAINS. ALLOWS TO GET THE
TOOLS EVEN IF YOU'LL TELL ME
THAT I'M FINE. BUT WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO DO OUR JOB. WITH THE
YOU FOR THAT ANSWERED TO WANNA
THINK YOU ALSO FOR INDULGING
THE SKY. STOP THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU SIR RUBIO
ASSERTED GROVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE
YOU LETTING ME COME BACK TO AND
ASK A FEW QUESTIONS ON THIS- ED.
I HATE. TO MAKE IT CALLING FROM
STOCKTON I. I UNDERSTAND THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL I LIKE THE
BILL I DO I THINK IF IT'S YOUR
EQUIPMENT YOU CAN REPAIR IT OR
HAVE SOMEBODY REPAIRED AT A
LOWER COST- BY ALL MEANS DO IT.
I DO HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE-
THE FINES AND PENALTIES- YOU
KNOW A THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY
FOR- AND THEN A TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY AND THEN FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY FOR
EVERY DAY- THAT A VIOLATION
OCCURS. I THINK THAT- I THINK
THAT'S A LOT. AND I MEAN A LOT
I REALIZE THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TO HOLD- MANUFACTURERS AND
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE BUT I JUST
THINK THAT THE CONTINUING
DOLLAR AMOUNT AND JESS DRIVES A
LITIGATION AND ATTORNEYS TO BE
INVOLVED IN- I THINK THERE'S A
BETTER WAY TO HANDLE THAT BT I
DO WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT I DO I
LIKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING I REALLY
DO BECAUSE I HAVE CONSTITUENTS
THAT HAVE THE SAME ISSUES
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE LEARN
THAT. PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
REPAIR AND THEIR OWN EQUIPMENT
AND SO I'M I DO AGREE WITH THAT
I JUST REALLY I HAVE A MIXED
ABOUT THOSE PENALTIES AGAINST-
MANUFACTURERS I HAVE AGING
STUDENTS THOSE FOR PENALTIES
AGAINST EMPLOYERS. BECAUSE
THEY'RE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGH AND
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO- THERE'S
NO CEILING. OF IT TOOK FORTY
FIVE DAYS AND FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TOOK THIRTY DAYS
TIMES. YOU KNOW BECAUSE THE
TECHNICAL ISSUES I HAVE A REAL
ANGST ON THAT. IT AFFECTS EVERY
NO THAT'S A THAT'S A QUESTION
WE'RE ALWAYS WILLING TO LOOK AT
THINGS BUT THAT'S FOR THE
DENIAL OF INFORMATION FOR
SOMEONE TO BE ABLE TO DO THEIR
JOB. RIGHT THAT'S THAT THAT IS
WHAT THE FINE IS FOR IT IS THE
OUTRIGHT DENIAL THE REFUSAL. OF
SOMEBODY TO PROVIDE DIVIDE THE
INFORMATION AT THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW. I APOLOGIZE I COULDN'T
HEAR WHAT YOU WERE SAYING. HI I
APOLOGIZE. I'M SORRY I SAID.
BUT THE FINE IS FOR THE DENIAL
RIGHT IF THIS BILL GOES INTO
AFFECT. STATE SOMEBODY'S
WORKING ON A RESPIRATOR AND
THEY HAVE BEEN BLOCKED OUT OF
IT. THAT IS WHAT THE FINE IS
FOR RIGHT IT'S NOT JUST. IT'S
NOT JUST SOMETHING BEING LATE
IT'S THE REFUSAL OF PROVIDING
THE INFORMATION. THAT WERE THAT
THE BILL ASK FOR. OKAY I
APOLOGIZE SO I MISUNDERSTOOD
THAT ON THE ANALYSIS SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THE FINE IF THE
BILL PASSES ONLY IF SOMEONE IS
FIXING THEIR EQUIPMENT AND THEY
GET BLOCKED OUT OF THE ABILITY
TO USE THAT EQUIPMENT WE'RE
SAYING THAT THE WE SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO IF THERE'S TRAINING
AS AS AT THE WITNESSES STATED.
OR IF THEY'RE EGGMAN INDEED IF
YOU CAN TALK TO YOU CAN TALKING
SIDEWAYS I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING
TO FACE CENTER GROVE BUT YOU
CAN TALK INTO THE MICROPHONE I
HAVE A BETTER THE HEALTH CHECK
UP YEAH THANK YOU SORRY. THANK
YOU THIS IS ALWAYS AWKWARD WHEN
YOU'RE SPEAKING TO PEOPLE AND
YOU CAN'T LOOK AT THEM. IN TO
WEARING MASKS. BUT I WAS SAYING
WHAT GOES INTO EFFECT IN THIS
BILL THE FINE IS FOR. SOMEBODY
NOT FOLLOWING THROUGH ON THAT
IT IS NOT JUST. BY ME. SO YES I
GUESS I GUESS YOUR ISSUE IS A
FEW YOU DON'T LIKE A FINE. FOR
SOMEBODY NOT FOLLOWING THE LAW
THEN. SO I UNDERSTOOD THE FINE
TO BE JUST ASSESSED IF- I HAD A
DIFFERENT MISGUIDED DIFFERENT
UNDERSTANDING AGAIN TRYING TO
LOOK AT YOU AND SPEAKING THE
MICROPHONE. A DIFFERENT
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE FINE
WAS FOR AND I DO APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT- THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING
IT. THANK YOU. CENTER TADO.
THANK YOU BOB BE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY JUST WANT TO DO I
ALWAYS HAVE JUST FROM
CHALLENGES WITH WITH- YOUR
SUPPORT ANY KIND OF BILL THAT
HAS ANY KIND OF FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT BUT I THINK THAT YOU
MEANWHILE I THINK THIS COULD-
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GOING TO HELP
AND- HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD WHEN APPROPRIATE OKAY
SO THE BILLS BEING MOVED BY
SARTANA PROVE YOU TIME AT
CENTER WINNER. THANK YOU MISTER
AND- HI I SUPPORT THE BILL I
THINK THE RIGHT. TO REPAIR IS
REALLY IMPORTANT- ALSO IT'S A
VERY COMPLICATED ISSUE IN A LOT
OF WAYS IN THIS IS. EARLY IN
THE PROCESS AND I'M CONFIDENT
AUTHOR WILL HAVE OPEN LINES OF
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL- AND ALL
ARE ENCOURAGED AND I GO TO
THANK YOU SIR LEYVA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I TOO WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. AND
I KNOW PEOPLE DON'T LIKE FINES
BUT WHAT I TELL PEOPLE OF
THERE'S NO ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM. THEN IT IS JUST A
SUGGESTION SO IF YOU DON'T
VIOLATE WHAT YOU'RE BEING ASKED
TO DO YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THE FINE SAID. YOU WON'T
HAVE TO PAY THEM. ENFORCEMENT
MAC MECHANISMS HELP MAKE SURE
PEOPLE DO WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO DO. THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ABOUT THE BILL HANDS UP.
EVERYONE OKAY. RIGHT SO SIR
EGGMAN AT FIRST I WANNA THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF-
WE DID NARROW THE BILL TO
HOSPITALS BECAUSE THERE IS THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY THE HOSPITAL HAS
TO REPORT. TO CMS- WE WANT TO
BE SURE WE HAD THAT ELEMENT OF.
SAFETY WITH IT IS NOT JUST SOME
RANDOM PERSON BE ABLE TO
DEMAND. THIS EQUIPMENT TO BILL
REPAIR EQUIPMENT THAT THEY'RE
NOT ACCOUNTABLE FOR- THROUGH
THE HOSPITAL SO I APPRECIATE
DOING THAT. I THINK I AT LEAST
ANALYSIS I THINK IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR SAYING THE FINES APPLY IF
THEY'RE INTENTIONALLY VIOLATING
THIS LAW I THINK IF. THE PEOPLE
NEEDS MORE CLARITY ON THAT I
GUESS I'M SURE YOU'LL WORK WITH
PEOPLE DOWN WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
PLAY GOTCHA. I THINK- DO WE BUT
THERE NEEDS TO BE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM- AND- YEAH. I THINK
IT'S AND AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE WE
DO WANT TO TRY TO GIVE PEOPLE
THE TOOLS AT THE SAME TIME
THESE ARE MEDICAL DEVICES SO I
KNOW THAT PERSONALLY OF THAT
THAT THAT'S A SENSITIVE ISSUE-
INSURING THAT IT'S REPAIRED
CORRECTLY- SO- BUT I'D
CERTAINLY SUPPORTING THE BILL
APPRECIATE THAT- YOUR- WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON MAKING
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS. WOULD YOU
LIKE CLOSE. I WOULD JUST THANK
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS I THINK ON THIS
IMPORTANT. ISSUE IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. K. THANK YOU SIR EGGMAN
SAID THE IS PUT BILLS THE NEW
BY SEN TADO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A- THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. A CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PAN HI CAN I AM
MELINDA'S. EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
AIKEN SALAS HI. AND SALAS I
GREW. HER TADO I RETURN LEYVA
HI LEYVA AYE LIMóN. LIMON SB
SIX OH FIVE HI LIMON AYE ROTH
IRA ROTH AYE RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE
WIENER. WIENER I. NINE SO THAT
BILL CURRENTLY HAS NINE VOTES
NINE ZERO WE WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL SAID ABSENT MEMBERS
RIGHT NEXTEL IS- ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB SEVEN SEVEN THREE BY
SIR ROCKED UP TO THE YOU
PRESENT FOR YOUR DESK- WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW ONE OF OUR
CONTINUED PRIORITIES IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IS ACCESS TO
TIMELY. AND RELIABLE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES PARTICULARLY IN
OUR SCHOOL SETTINGS WE'VE
ESTABLISHED FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES OVER THE LAST.
FEW YEARS LIKE THE MENTAL
HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES ACT.
SEEKING TO INCENTIVIZE STRONGER
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COUNTIES
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO HELP
ADDRESS THE EXISTING GAPS IN
THAT IN THAT CASE. THROUGH THE
USE OF PROP SIXTY THREE
FUNDING. BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE AND NEEDS
TO BE DONE QUICKLY. AS WE
RECOVER FROM COVERT NINETEEN
OUR STUDENTS DESERVE ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE SERVICES TO PROMOTE
HEALING. SCHOOLS OF COURSE
SERVICE IMPORTANT FRONTLINE
ACCESS FOR SCREENING FOR
IDENTIFICATION AND IN SOME
CASES FOR DELIVERY OF CARE. BUT
OUR SCHOOLS CANNOT DO IT ALONE
CREATING A MORE ROBUST SYSTEM
FOR IDENTIFICATION INTERVENTION
AND TREATMENT WILL REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT THROUGH
BOTH THE HEALTH CARE AND
EDUCATION SECTORS. AND FRANKLY
ESTABLISHING MORE EFFICIENT
PARTNERSHIPS FOR THE DELIVERY
OF CARE THIS BILL LEVERAGES
STATE INVESTMENT FOR
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL RESOURCES
BY ESTABLISHING INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS FOR MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS TO PROVIDE SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
IN COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
EDUCATION AUTHORITIES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
DEDICATES FOUR HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND
TO A SIMILAR INCENTIVE BASED
PAYMENT PROGRAM THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THIS BILL SB SEVEN
SEVEN THREE WILL WORK THROUGH
THE DETAILS OF HOW THAT PROGRAM
WILL OPERATE. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH BOTH HEALTH AND
EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE EFFICIENT AND
APPROPRIATE OPERABILITY OF THIS
PROGRAM. I HAVE WILL LIVE BORN
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND J. C.
COOPER CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR IN
STATE MEDIC MEDICAID DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. AVAILABLE FOR
ANY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. READY
TO RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER ROCK.
EIGHT TO HAVING BOTH. THE
DIRECTOR OF THE H. YES AS WELL
AS OUR MEDICAID DIRECTOR VEILED
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT FOR FORMAL
TESTIMONY WE ACTUALLY HAVE
NEITHER TO PEOPLE TESTIFYING IN
FAVOR OR IN OPPOSITION BUT WE
DO HAVE. TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
CLEANERS- WHICH TO TESTIFY- SO.
I THINK WILL DO IS ALLOW THEM
TO TESTIFY FIRST AND THEN WE'LL
TAKE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY OF
WITNESSES TO SUPPORT OPPOSITION
SO. WHO I HAVE- MODERATOR OF
COMPLETE PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE WE HAVE. WHEN A COOKMAN.
COMMENCES FROM HIS THE INTERIM
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER TO
LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND LETICIA GARCIA
POLICY DIRECTOR OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WHO BELIEVE ARE BOTH
HERE TO TESTIFY THE- ON THE
BILL BUT WITHOUT A FORMAL
POSITION EITHER WAY. SO OF EACH
WITNESS YOU HAVE A MAXIMUM OF
TWO MINUTES TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY SO BEGIN WITH. THE NAY-
KOOPMANS IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE
PLEASE BEGIN. AND MISTER CHAIR
I DO NOT SHOW THAT WHEN THEY A
COOP AND IT'S CONNECTED. OKAY
SO- FROM THAT WE DON'T HAVE IT
ONCE AND LOCAL HEALTH PLANS A
CALIFORNIA. WE DO HAVE- WITH
GARCIA ON THE LINE OKAY WELL
RIGHT OKAY SO FOR. THE STATE
DID LET'S GO AHEAD AND LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE LETTER TO GARCIA
FROM THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU- IDENTITY SECURITY ON
BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS I
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
PROPOSAL TO INVEST FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDS TO
BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ESTABLISH PARTNERSHIPS WITH
SCHOOL AND COUNTY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH WE DON'T THINK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PRIORITIZING
THE CRITICAL ISSUE IN MENTAL
HEALTH WHICH HAS ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED DURING HELD AT
NINETEEN LASTLY WE THANK
SENATOR RAP ROCK FOR
INTRODUCING SB SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE WHICH PROVIDES THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS
WHAT THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A
MEANINGFUL CONVERSATION ON THE
BEST WAY. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL CANDY CAN MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS WITH
UNIQUE AND HISTORIC TIME
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AS PART OF THE
COALITION IS WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IN HIS STAFF TO HELP
DEFINE A SPECIFIC AREAS OF
INVESTING IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OUR SUPERINTENDENT ESTABLISHED
FIFTY TO MENTAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE TO SUPPORT OUR
DISTRICTS AND STUDENTS I WILL
DISTRICTS HAVE IDENTIFIED TWO
CRITICAL AREAS THAT NEED FOR
EXPANDING PROGRAM TO SERVE MORE
STUDENTS NOT ONLY MEDICARE
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS BUT ALSO
STUDENTS WITH HEALTH INSURANCE.
AND UNLIMITED AND LIMITED
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WHICH IS WHY FOR ALSO
SUPPORTING SB FIVE OH EIGHT BY
SENATOR STERN ANOTHER KEY AREA
IT PROVIDING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING TO
SCHOOL AND MENTAL HEALTH STAFF
VOCAL IDENTIFIED SIX REGIONS IN
OUR COUNTY WITH GREAT WITH THE
GREATEST CAPTAIN SURFACES AND
WE'LL SET UP ONLY CENTERS
DURING THE NEXT SCHOOL YEAR TO
MEET THE NEEDS WE HAVE FOUND
THAT ESTABLISHING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS VERY COSTLY
SUCH A FACILITY FURNITURE
TREATING INDIVIDUAL
CONFIDENTIAL BASIS PURCHASING
SOFTWARE AND TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS AND FINALLY THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH CONTRACTORS TO
SECURE PROVIDERS. IN PERSON IN
TELEHEALTH SERVICES THE ONE
TIME FUNDS ARE JUST NOT ENOUGH
SCHOOLS ARE ON THE FRONTLINE OF
SERVING OUR KIDS AND WE MUST
FIND A WAY TO INVEST BEYOND
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND PROVIDE ON
GOING SIGNED ALL STUDENTS FOR
THE ARE ASKED SITE. WE
RECOGNIZE THE BILL IS FILLED
AND- BUT THIS ISSUE WITH
CHILDREN'S PLEASE WRAP TO NOT
BEING. WE ASK THAT YOU SB SEVEN
SEVEN THREE TODAY TO COME
CONGRESS. AND REQUIRE. THAT
EDUCATION THEY CALL BEING IN
THE COMING. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH-
SO I DO I- THAT WOULD DO HAVE.
A LA KOOPMAN. THE LINE SHE IS
ON. THE LINE NUMBER THREE
THIRTY NINE- SO- MONARCHY
PLEASE FIND LINE THREE THIRTY
NINE I BELIEVE SHE WILL BE
THERE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE SHE
MAY HAVE CALLED IN THE WRONG
LINE OR SOMETHING BUT. ALL
RIGHT ADELINE ST THIRTY NINE IS
NOW OPEN OKAY. YEAH HELLO THAT
ELECTED CHAIRMAN CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES CAN YOU HEAR ME MISTER
CHAIRMAN YES SORRY FOR THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY THEN-
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
BRIEFLY SPEAK THIS AFTERNOON
MANY CLINICS AND THEN THEN THE
INTERIM CEO WITH A LOCAL HELP
AND THE CALIFORNIA. SO WE ARE
SUPPORTED THE CONCEPT PROPOSED
IN SB SEVEN SEVENTY THREE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION BUDGET
PROPOSAL. WE DO THINK IT WILL
INCREASE ACCESS TO NEEDED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH UNIT. AND
ENHANCED PARTNERSHIP THAT- THAT
NEED TO BE ENHANCE THAT AT
SCHOOL LEVEL AND BETWEEN PLANT
COUNTY THEN PROVIDER. HOWEVER
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE PROPOSAL REQUIRED NEW
OR- SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED
PARTNERSHIP. BETWEEN PLANNED
COUNTY THE ANKLES. AT THE SAME
TIME AS PLANNED AND THEIR
PROVIDERS WILL BE IMPLEMENTING
CALLIE PROPOSALS SUCH AS
ENHANCE. CARE MANAGEMENT AND
ANALYTICS SERVICES. BECAUSE THE
POLICE A THING LEFT FOR ALL
PARTNERS. WE DO BELIEVE ADVANCE
PH FOR RETURN THAT WILL BE
NECESSARY. AND WE ALSO HAVE
SEVERAL QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROGRAM STRUCTURE AND
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY AS HAS
BEEN PREVIOUSLY NOTED IN THE
BILL NOW SAYS AND BY THE L. E.
L. AND WE DO WANT TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION- ON THE
DETAILS AND LOOK FORWARD TO.
PARTNERING HEY ENHANCE THE
PROGRAM AND MAKE SURE THAT. IF
SUCCESSFUL AND IT'S A LOT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THREE. ALL RIGHT-
SO THAT'S OUR- FORMAL TESTIMONY
AND BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. WE ARE IN
OUR LIVES. LAST BILL ON THE
AGENDA BEFORE WE GO TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THE SO YOU
PLEASE NOTIFY THE- SERGEANTS
KEEP PLEASE NOTIFY THE- MEMBERS
WHO ARE. NOT PRESENT- THAT-
PRICE FAIRLY SHORTLY WE WILL BE
GOING TO THE SENATE CALENDAR
AND ALSO- OPENING THE OPENING
OF THE- ROLLS THE BILL'S ON
CALL. ALRIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO TESTIMONY FIRST OF ALL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN THREE- WILL GO UP
TO THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE OR
THE PUBLIC GALLERY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEM NO ONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO WAS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN THREE- JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE S. B.
SEVEN SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE. ZERO AND ALIGN
THIRTY FIVE- MY BECAUSE OF ALL.
YOUR NEW MISTER CHERN NUMBERS
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WITH THE
SUPPORT OF COMMENDED POSITION
HAPPY TO CONTINUE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE THREE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
YOUR MY KIDS UP. THANK YOU AN
INDICATOR AFTER GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR TO ALIGN WITH
SB FIVE OKAY. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. IN THAT LINE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. BUDGETARY COUNTY
TOOK A ROPE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH MISS
GARCIA MYSTIC IS REMARKS
REQUESTING FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH SCHOOL
GROUPS THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU NOW LET'S
MOVE IS THAT TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN SEVEN
THREE. LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SAYING NO IN THE
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE
THROUGH TWENTY FORTY CINNAMON
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TO
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN SEVEN
THREE AGAINST NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. SEVEN SEVEN
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AND MR SURE THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME THANK
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. CENTER
EGGMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I JUST WANT TO COMPLEMENT THE-
THE AUTHOR AND I'M A PROUD CO
AUTHOR ON THIS AND LIKE AND
LIKE THE BILL I TALKED ABOUT WE
CAN ALL AGREE ON PRINCIPLES BUT
IT'S GOT TO GET THE POLICY IN
PLACE AND WHAT WE'VE ALL HAD A
LOT OF INTEREST IN INCREASING
MENTAL HEALTH IN SCHOOLS AND
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT ANOTHER
PROPOSITION ABOUT THAT EARLIER
THIS IS A WAY THAT I THINK IS
REALLY GOING TO GO FAR TO
ACHIEVING THAT GOAL- OF
ACTUALLY. PUTTING IN THE POLICY
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET AND PAY
FOR MORE MENTAL HEALTH CARES IN
OUR SCHOOLS FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE SO I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT
THANK YOU THE BILLS MOVE BY SIR
EDMUND AT APPROPRIATE. TIMES
HELLO THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CASEY NONE- A SERAPH AND WANTED
I TO WANT IT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AT
FREE SHEET THAT. MILLION CO
AUTHORS IS THE CHAIR OF OUR
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE HEALTH
HUMAN SERVICES WILL HAVE A LOT
TO SAY AND HOW THIS IS GOING TO
GET. PUT INTO THE BUDGET. AS A
PEDIATRICIAN WHO ACTUALLY. WAS
THE MEDICAL CONSULT FROM A
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR WE
ACTUALLY FOCUSED ON. TRYING TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. AND COORDINATION
BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND- HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
I LOOK FOR A- LOT OF WORK IN
PROGRESS- I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
WORK IN PROGRESS. APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND LEADING
THIS DISCUSSION. AND THIS ONLY
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU AS WELL
CENTER EGGMAN ON THIS AS WELL-
BIG PASSION OF MINE. SO CENTER
ROUGHLY TWO TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO
THIS BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER EGGMAN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CONSULT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AM
A LONDON HI MELINDA'S I EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
AYE GROVE AYE GROVE AYE HER
TADO HI A TOTAL AYE LEYVA LEYVA
AYE LEóN. LIMON S. SEVEN THREE
HI LIMON HI ROSS ALL RIGHT ROTH
AYE RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE WIENER
ALL RIGHT WIENER HI. ELEVEN
OKAY THAT BILL IS ALEX- LEVIN
ZERO THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S
NOW MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR OF THREE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SP FOUR SIXTY BY MYSELF-
THAT'S JUST DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BELIEVE. WELL IN
SCHOOL THAT THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS I'M NUMBER FIVE
SB 47% RUBIO THAT'S ALSO DO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS AND THEN I
DON'T NUMBER TEN SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE BY THE COMMITTEE-
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH. AND THAT
IS ALSO DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IS THERE A
MOTION. SOME OF OKAY THE NEW BY
CENTER LEYVA CONSOLED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CLICK SENT
CALENDAR PAN HI CAN I AM
MELINDA'S AYE MELINDA'S AYE
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ AND
SALAS I GROWTH AYE GROVE AYE
HER TADO HI A TOTAL AYE LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE. LEE MOON. AMONG
CONSENT CAN HI LIMON I ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO. AYE RUBIO AYE
WIENER ALL RIGHT WE AYE.
CONSENT CALENDARS. ELEVEN ALL
RIGHT NOW LET'S GO BACK THROUGH
THE ROLE. OKAY THAT. IS OUT ALL
RIGHT SO WE'RE JUST GONNA START
FROM THE TOP HERE SO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE. FOLLOW HIM NUMBER
ONE IT'S I'M NUMBER ONE SB
SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS. S. OKAY A
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL ON AYE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB SIXTY FIVE
BY CENTER SKINNER GROVE HIGH
PROFILE HER TADO FOR TOTAL I IN
THE MONTH. LIAM SB SIX FIVE HI.
LIMóN HI. THAT BILL SB SIXTY
FIVE IS HALF PAST ELEVEN ZERO.
WE NOW GO LIVE TO CALL ON ITEM
NUMBER TWO S. B. EIGHTY BY SIR
MCGUIRE- CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS GROWTH
HI GROVE I HER TITLE HI HER
TOTAL EISENMAN. LEE KNOWN AS
THE EIGHTY HI LIMON HI. THAT'S
THREE EIGHTY IS OUT OF IT'S
PAST ELEVEN ZERO NEXT ITEMS I
AND NUMBER THREE SORREL IF THE
CALL ON ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
TWO TWENTY NINE BY CENTER DOLLY
SIX EIGHT PLEASE. CONSULT THESE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROF AYE GROVE AYE HER TADO I
HER TOTAL AYE LEYVA HI LEYVA HI.
SB TWO TWENTY NINE IS OUT
ELEVEN ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FIVE NINETEEN BY
CENTER WIENER- BECAUSE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROWTH NO GROWTH NO HER TADO.
LIMON. NO NOT REALLY YEAH RUBIO.
SIX TWO. YEAH OKAY SB FIVE
NINETEEN IS OUT. SIX TO. NEXT
ITEM IS- ITEM NUMBER SEVEN- BY
CENTER IT'S SO WILL LIFT THE
CALL AND I AM NUMBER SEVEN SP
FIVE FIVE EIGHT BY SENATOR
CAPPIELLO SECRETARY PLEASE
DON'T PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MELENDEZ. GROF HI GROVE
HI. ZERO ZERO OKAY SB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT FIVE FIVE EIGHT IS OUT
TEN ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX OH FIVE AYE
SIR EGGMAN CONSULTANT I WILL
HAVE TO CALL ON SB SIX OH FIVE
A CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ
GROVE HIGH. PROFILE. SB FIVE
SIX OH FIVE IS OUT TEN ZERO.
RIGHT THIS CONCLUDES THE AGENDA
FOR THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND I THINK
ALL THE INDIVIDUAL TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
IN WRITING TO THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
KLUGER TESTIMONY AND OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
WITH THAT AGAIN THANK YOU TO
ALL THE STAFF AND- TECHNICAL
PEOPLE MAKE THIS- DURING GO SO
SMOOTHLY THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE HEALTH IS
ADJOURNED.